[Laughter]
thank you
hey everybody happy Friday
um
Jenny's going oh [ __ ] already before the
[ __ ] even started we we were up at the
biker bar at the Oasis I went to the
biker yeah I got pictures of it and
everything to prove it
and [ __ ] yeah now it was cool it was
cool we had a good time right yeah you
liked it I had a good time I was there a
couple hours before she was I had to go
and like make a drug run and [ __ ] I
had to go buy some drugs yeah I had to
go buy some drugs
so I end up there and I'm like [ __ ]
yeah that's mine right yeah okay
the skinnier jar right and then I'm like
Jenny come on down here everybody wants
to meet you
so she shows up I introduced her to a
bunch of people who had been waiting
forever to see her and like they thought
I was like Sasquatch like I didn't
really exist they didn't think she
existed I was like okay yeah she does
exist yeah see I'm real yeah we had a
good time
yeah it was really fun it was really fun
you want some little Debbies
no not right now I'm gonna get a Little
Debbie he's gonna get a little bit he
went to Dollar General yeah and got
Little Debbie's
they didn't have any of the well they
didn't have like the of my favorite ones
though they had oatmeal pies which okay
and they had like the nutter what are
they called they're not Nutter butter
yeah they're like the wafer peanut
butter ones those are good though it's a
Nutter bar I got Nutter bars yeah see
those are good Nutter bars that's Nutter
bars and I got lizard I got the Little
Debbie Oatmeal cookie cakes yeah yeah
this is some [ __ ] uh redneck [ __ ]
here
how much are they charging for a box of
those nowadays four dollars holy [ __ ] I
remember you get it I remember back in
my day yeah they used to only be 99
Cents four no four dollars gives you a
case a half a cake oh okay I'm talking
about like the one that had like how
many were in there no there's I guess it
depending on how small they're still
inexpensive
it's kind of like a big old Kit Kat with
peanut butter in the middle of it yeah
it's like peanut butter Wafers those are
actually pretty good I ate one of those
earlier before I came out of the bar wow
because he went down to the bar earlier
no it's all right I had one earlier
we ate some pumpkin soup before right
before the show started like we had a
pug a mug of like pumpkin soup
I had one of these before you summoned
me down to the bar
this is Friday afternoon I finished most
of the [ __ ] I had to do
and
he messaged me earlier and he was like
well don't come down right now because
it's mostly old dudes and it'd be like
really boring yeah old old dudes listen
to country music which yeah I'm not into
that [ __ ] all that but like after some
of like maybe young well we're talking
younger like our age so like 40s and 50s
like when they came down there and like
the music was more in a classic rock
kind of a and I was like all right well
I kind of like was at a stopping point
so I came down there he was very excited
that I came down there I don't think
that he think that I was that I don't
think you actually believed that I was
gonna come down there at any point
we're calling it classic rock
it wasn't classic rock from our point of
view it would be a classic rock from
like our children's point of view if we
had trolls room it was
um
well what was playing
well um music mostly from the 80s and
90s well now some of this stuff because
somebody I don't know who it was because
I know you put on
Billy Idol and you know [ __ ] like that
but there was also like a lot of Neil
Young in there somebody was really into
Neil Young because it was like three
Neil Young songs that was just like some
Led Zeppelin stuff like that which is
fine that's fine
better than the [ __ ] they were playing
before
okay well I'm glad you warned me about
that like I said because I wouldn't have
gone there like Jenny this [ __ ] [ __ ]
sucks man don't come
down yet yeah he messaged me at like
three what is it like 3 15. yeah I was
like well now you can come down because
all the old guys that were playing
country music have left
man terrible
yeah I mean I can put up with a lot of
stuff but I'm not real into country
music other than like I like old country
you know what I mean like I like Johnny
Cash I like Hank Williams I like that
kind of [ __ ] that's more like rockabilly
because I really like rockabilly from
there Jenny and Amy finally met each
other
my old wife and my new wife finally met
each other
and they loved each other
yeah I'm I'm kind of I'm pretty sure
that like um Amy wanted to have sex with
me yeah she does
no I showed Amy pictures of you and said
God she's so [ __ ] hot
her boobs are [ __ ] awesome
and he's got badass boobs too but Amy's
the uh
Amy is the
biker
bartender for the entire [ __ ] area
she knows all the [ __ ] gangs she's
cute as [ __ ] she's cool yeah no she
liked you she thinks you're awesome
I come across better in person like
because I know like a lot of you guys
other than you Dave like you know me in
real life but um you know and I've known
him a long time but I kind of feel like
maybe I come across good on video I'm
not really sure but like in videos and
uh photos I feel like uh the me isn't
coming across you know what I'm saying
we were talking about this a little bit
at the bar I kind of feel like I come
across better in person maybe in some
ways no is that true or not yeah well no
you have to see it to believe it
because I entered I introduced you to
[ __ ] um
my boy also and he's like okay yeah yeah
she's real she's real they didn't think
she was real like I said I'm like
[ __ ] I'm like okay yeah she's real
I'm like the skunk ape right
but every now and then you get exciting
yeah no Amy thought you were [ __ ]
great she was like [ __ ] oh yes I I
got that yeah
she wasn't quite sure you gotta showed
her pictures and she's like is that
written but then she saw you and she's
like oh yeah yeah she's she's cool well
like I said it's kind of like she lives
across the street from us she does yeah
yeah well we kept telling her to like
come over and I even told her to like
when I came there I was like you know
she wants to go to mannequins now she's
like we need to take her to mannequin
yeah well the thing is is that uh she
only she only works three days a week
she needs a couple other work days
you know what I mean as a bartender I'll
hook her up with with Tom big Tom will
give her another night she needs a
couple other nights
Dave is here we talked about him earlier
hello you two he says I get the same
thing with my wife she's like my Harvey
but she isn't into the whole club bar
thing anymore I mean I love my bars not
biker bars but not so much I mean well
it's I don't like I don't have to think
against bikers it's just that I don't
really like I don't really like the
rednecky thing so it's like if it goes
too far into the red necky Daytona kind
of [ __ ] yeah like I'm not into that yeah
and biker bars around around here are 50
50. it'll be super redneck which she
doesn't like or it'll be more Rock and
Hard Rock which is a lot better I like
that a lot better you liked it that's
what I mean it's like when I went in
there like honestly like all the song
like it was like you played some songs
yeah um and that was fine but even like
the [ __ ] that other people were playing
that was fine like I said it was like
Led Zeppelin Neil Young I like all that
stuff so it's just kind of like you know
it depends on the it depends on the uh
on the age group
you know what I mean the Generation X
generation and lower as far as bikers go
now they're pretty cool it's pretty good
it's the older it's like
the older Generations that their [ __ ] is
kind of lame okay it's too lame
too much the Eagles too much
um
[ __ ] uh uh Leonard Skynyrd it's just
it's too Boomer yeah it's Boomer I mean
honestly like the eagles I'll allow it
yeah I'll allow it but when it gets into
like I said like Leonard Skynyrd or like
Molly Hatchet yeah then I'm gonna start
getting like
then I'm gonna start getting like that
even though I'm gonna say free bird and
some of that [ __ ] and and old now if I
was drunk enough I might be and I might
be like yeah yeah yeah yeah some of it
is good it's just that it's played out
you know I mean Seth said I hate the
[ __ ] Eagles a lot of people do a lot
of people that's bad I don't hate them
it's just that I mean they well they
don't Inspire the same kind of like ire
in me that maybe other bands do
but you know because like I said if they
come under the bar I'll be like okay but
I'm not gonna like get [ __ ] aggro
about it but I mean some bands I would
but it's not bad the older biker crowd
which is like RH I'll [ __ ] throw on
Ramstein they [ __ ] love it throwing
Ramstein what else was I throwing on
um well you put Sisters of Mercy cover
of Gimme Shelter yeah yeah old Sisters
of Mercy they like all that it's just uh
it's just the older ones and Billy Idol
yeah he puts like a couple of um yeah
James Bond themes like the Chris Cornell
one yeah I really like that now and that
all like [ __ ] another way to die
[ __ ] uh from that's Alicia Alicia
Keys I like a lot of bond themes
and X generation and lower uh as far
ex-gen and lower
um or younger
love that [ __ ] it's just Boomers boomers
are kind of come on man get over that
[ __ ] well that's what I mean and we were
talking about this a little bit at the
bar because I was like well
you know when I grew up when I was in
junior high in high school like in the
80s
you know there was a very clear
distinction between it's like look here
I am over here listening to Bauhaus and
Alien Sex Fiend and it's like you know
the people that were into like you know
chart music or whatever they were
listening to Tiffany Debbie Gibson but
also there was kind of like a holdover
from the 70s also so you had kind of
like you know there was like [ __ ] like
like adult Rock like Hall and Oates and
everything
so you know back in the 80s very very
uncool like you know to say that you
liked Hall and Oates especially if you
were into New Wave or Punk or anything
like that but one thing like getting
older
now I can like look back and listen to
Hall and Oates for example that's just
like the first example I thought of and
you can listen to them
without all of the cultural baggage
about it and being like you know what
some of the songs were like we're okay
like that was pretty good
um you know I wasn't into it at the time
because it wasn't cool and it's I don't
know but now that that you know moment
has passed so you don't have all of that
like I said baggage around it then you
can just like appreciate it for a song
and it's just like yeah that's like a
pretty good song I still probably
wouldn't buy it but I'm not gonna you
know get all [ __ ]
upset about it if somebody plays it you
know what I mean because we were talking
about man-eater and I was like I didn't
like it at the time but it's like now
I'm just gonna that's a pretty good song
I liked it at the time I didn't I didn't
want to get that I was a little kid I
was like yeah it's better
I didn't know any better it was this
[ __ ] was on the radio and I was like
yeah it was yeah that's a good song I I
actually liked early notes
it was like 13. yeah I was like that
shit's good yeah it was though
she's a rich girl he's going too far and
it doesn't really matter anyway
on Old Man's money yeah yeah yeah that
kind of [ __ ] get stuck in my head all
the time yeah whatever reason I didn't
have to hear it it just get stuck in my
head somebody like mentioned now it'll
be stuck in my head for like that yeah
yeah so thank you
but yeah that's what happens yeah Zach
says I love the cover of Immigrant Song
from The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
yeah I mean oh okay
yeah come to the land of the Isis I'm
not like I'm not a huge fan of Led
Zeppelin but they did have like a lot of
good they had a good a lot of good [ __ ]
very good very talented yeah yeah I like
I liked them I liked him but it was from
a certain place in time but yeah and
well I think a lot of my when I was
younger because I was trying to like
talk about this at the bar and I was
like I'm not really sure if I was
getting my point across but I was all
over her at the bar he was yeah well he
had been there for a couple hours before
me so he was like pretty tanked when I
got there yeah
I had to I was you got to understand
something The Oasis Cafe The Oasis
it's kind of yeah the Oasis every time
you say that
is Florida it's like the South's version
of the [ __ ] Moss icely [ __ ] star
Port all right uh it's the place well
you got to go there long enough there's
[ __ ]
I mean yeah it's like Friday afternoon
yeah so it's like there was like you
know some bikers and some other gyms
there but that's about it it's a place
it's it's a it's a hive of scum and
villain
she was there during a good time though
um
we had fun I always have fun when I go
there it's the Gangsta hang out
that's all right yeah through all the
bikers biker [ __ ] bars biker clubs
hang out yeah it was pretty low-key but
that's okay I was just like sitting
there having a couple drinks and like
watching Catfish on TV and yeah
listening to whatever people put on them
listen to whatever people put on the
jukebox which was a lot of the [ __ ] was
yours but right like I said most of the
other stuff was Neil Young which like I
said I'm fine I like I was spinning I
like I was spinning because uh the
jukeboxes you can link up with it with
your phone
and you can download a uh an app
and then pay with your
with your [ __ ] ATM or with your bank
card
and you can start you can be the DJ if
you have enough money I'm always the DJ
when I [ __ ] show up there I'll
[ __ ] play all kinds although one
thing that kind of made me laugh is that
you had paid in advance yeah and you
wanted that uh ROM scene so yeah
Ramstein yeah yeah and somebody like I
feel like one of the drunk ladies yeah
like one of the older ladies like went
up there was trying to make it stop and
was like trying to like put something
else on you almost stop it though well
no because somebody paid for that [ __ ]
so yeah play it
so I thought that was kind of I wasn't
worried about her this year she said
what what is that like [ __ ] you which I
thought was very funny you can put
yourself you can move yourself forward
in the line but you gotta you gotta pay
more well yeah that's what they're gonna
do that's what they're doing but she she
didn't have the money to do that she
just yeah she just wanted the [ __ ] she
wanted to probably hear Leonard she
wasn't yeah she she wanted somebody she
wasn't Adept at [ __ ] uh
because Tom's over here with this tablet
yeah I got the attack control she's over
there I'm like no
no
if you want to jump in front of me it
takes money and you got to have a
[ __ ] app on your phone but it's gonna
take [ __ ] didn't even have a phone
yeah yeah yeah yeah that runs George
Harrison yeah what am I talking about I
don't know no but it was good and um
um
Amy thought she was great maybe he was
like oh she's awesome I'm cool see I was
like kind of stressed out because when
you said yeah here's how I do yeah like
when he said the thing he's like well if
you're gonna come down like come down
now because all the old dudes that are
playing country music have left and like
you know it's it's okay now and I was
kind of at a stopping place in my show
I'm like wow what the hell I'll come
down there but then I was like then I
stopped and I was like holy [ __ ] like
what shirt should I wear like what shoe
should I wear like how Shady my hair
like how should you am I gonna be a
disappointment because I know that
you've like talked me up to everybody
down there and I feel like if I walk in
it's gonna be like this thing where like
the record's gonna scratch and like I
kind of like yeah thought about it like
that yeah because I know that you've
just told everybody about me and I'm
like oh now everybody now it's going to
be a big let down like when I actually
show up yeah no not at all it didn't
seem to be I mean everybody's saying
this way they're like everybody seemed
like way more into me than I was
expecting yeah
and I was like all right all right yeah
I don't know I don't know what you told
them but okay well I showed pictures I
show the show and everything okay I
showed this show you guys are watching
now I mean one of the old one of the
older guys was like kind of like hey you
know I have blue hair and I was like
yeah not today yeah because I showed a
picture of you I don't have the wiggle
with the blue hair and the horns oh okay
oh yeah yeah I know she's coming here
yeah and uh my friend was like okay I'll
wait for her
you showed up you didn't have the blue
hair in the horns but he didn't care
well obviously I'm not gonna wear the
blue hair and the horns she's ready to
go over there yeah holy crap it's the
middle of the day for Grace
Louie says uh my uncle saw Led Zeppelin
back in the day best concert he's ever
been to he told me I'm sure they were
good yeah I'm sure they were out there
yeah I was never like a huge fan but
it's like I appreciate them more now
than I did at the time yeah Senora stick
says Jenny or not a day over 30 years
old I wish
we're 20 years old 30 years old yeah
that was like two decades ago yeah
babies are 30. which is crazy yeah I
know I could have kids that were 30. I'm
halfway to 60. I'm [ __ ] almost 55.
we're not halfway well you're like a way
more yeah yeah much closer to 50 60.
yeah five years I'll be 60.
yeah
yeah
it doesn't seem that way because people
are not really aging the way they used
to depends but and then I'm gonna say
well no some people are aging like they
used to other people are it depends on
who you are and what you know and how
much money you have that has a lot to do
with it some of it has to do I kind of
feel like with your attitude as well
attitude has something to do with it
genetics uh knowledge
understanding hormone replacement and
how all that works
uh knowledge has a lot to do with it
there were
look I'm close to 60 they were there
were very few guys like me in the 60s
and 70s now there's a bunch of us
yeah yeah that's a good thing yeah
I kind of feel like everybody looked
like crap like when they hit [ __ ] 35
well honestly like if you look at even
movies that came out in the you know
like the 50s and 60s you know like
people that were playing teenagers and
it's like oh they were 35 at the time of
like what 35 that looks like about 45.
yeah
um you know not to be mean or anything
but people did look a lot older back
then not everybody obviously but a lot
of people did look older back then than
they would nowadays
uh Daniel Rowling said who would win in
a death match uh
Deathmatch versus Style movie Harry
Warden or Michael Myers probably Michael
Myers because I kind of feel like
Michael Myers it's more established that
he has
possibly Supernatural Powers Harry
Warden not so much I mean he's just kind
of like
is it Canon that he has Supernatural
Powers I don't think so
you know he's just a minor and he got
stuck in the [ __ ] and like he killed
some people with a pickaxe and
the end I kind of feel like Michael
Myers has a lot more so I I'm gonna I'm
gonna give that to Michael Myers just
saying people are telling me to check
messenger
Tammy says Jenny slams to The Swinging
Doors and the Music Stops that's kind of
what I was I didn't think that was gonna
happen but like in some ways
I don't know is that weird like I felt
like you would probably talked me up so
much to people that it's like when I
came in that I was bound to be like a
letdown
no is that [ __ ] up to thick
that's how I roll though
I'm always kind of so why so I was like
worried about it like when I was getting
ready I was just kind of like
um
like I'm probably not wearing the right
thing it's like I'm probably my hair
isn't the right isn't right and it's
like you know what I mean but everybody
seemed really enthused so okay
like I said I think I come off better in
person
you know
then
oh yeah we just took that earlier
I don't even know what I was saying what
were you saying what were you talking
about I don't know well some of the
videos we talked to we till we sent them
to Sophie yeah but I don't know if
that's the one we sent to Sophie or we
just no it's not yeah it's the one that
was in my okay uh gallery
we were saying something I don't
remember what it was we were talking
about I don't remember either yeah I
don't remember either
Oracle says Tom and Jenny I'm gonna be
cooking the Thai red curry from your
cookbook for Thanksgiving okay because
my husband has to work that night so I
want to make something special but not
turkey ham okay man I hope you like it
because I really really like that recipe
I really like that Thai recipe we don't
make it a lot but whenever we make it
it's like super good
there's a bunch of stuff you can do with
those curry recipes
I like it the little Curry yeah tins
right I like the yellow one that's my
favorite but because I don't know like
what's that what's that brand name
called I think I said it was it Penang
or no that's no no that's the name of
the thing yeah I can't remember like the
name of the brand that sells it like we
get it at the Asian market but they have
like a bunch of different ones and one
of them is yellow one of them's green
one of them is pinkish like hot pink and
one's red and green the green one's the
hottest
the yellow one is most like
I kind of feel like I don't know if it's
the mildest it's like the mildest or
like the most
that's the one we use for like the
peanut butter curries which are my
favorite
but
um
yeah all of those are good I think the
yellow is my favorite though the pink
one's good too but it's kind of hot for
me
as the older I get like I can't really
eat hot foods that much anymore like
without regretting it you know
uh Zach said it would be hilarious if
every time he walked into a room there's
a record scratch for no reason I know
like maybe I should carry something in
my pocket that goes you know what I mean
so it's like that well that said I
didn't really think that was gonna
happen but like I said I was kind of
like I was very aware of having to live
up to people's expectations and so I was
like stressed out about that
I think maybe that's the reason that I
didn't want to go back down there like
earlier because I was just kind of like
I know that you had probably like told
them like oh she's so awesome and all
this other stuff and then like I would
turn up and they'd be like yeah she's
done awesome
what are you talking about
but you know I I do think that I come
across better in person so you know
John Smith said my father was 55 when I
was born holy [ __ ] yeah
that's like I said it's
you know I don't I don't know how old
you are but it's not as old as it used
to be that used to be like oh that's an
old person but nowadays I don't really
think of that as an old person and I
don't know if that's just because I'm
only five years off that myself but you
know
Oracle says we love that recipe it's
delicious as heck and there's a local
company that has Thai chili powder that
works well in the dish we'll see there
you go
that is that's one of my favorite Thai
curries actually
that's awesome that people like that
[ __ ] that that uh
that Thai recipe
yeah it is good I got a [ __ ] ton of that
Thai curry downstairs makes you want to
make it now and I and I I pulled out a
bunch of uh
sweet potatoes from from my garden
some of them aren't really big enough to
eat but they'd be great pureed
yeah with pumpkin because you know we
had like we we bought like a fish tank
we've made like a pumpkin soup and we
had that like before the show started
yeah
and it's really really good but
John Robertson said hey guys I was
wondering Jenny if you had heard of all
gods of Appalachia podcast it's a horror
Anthology podcast it uh tells an
all-over story it's like Lovecraft mixed
with Appalachian culture I haven't but
that sounds exactly like right up my
alley so I will definitely have to look
that up look at this what
what the [ __ ] Pookie is what can you see
her no the weekend's here she's backed
out she's grabbing a [ __ ] fish
and then she's her little minty yeah is
that her little minty grabbing his no
grabbing the Nancy huh snort it and
she's looking at me you're like what
that's good she loves those mint toys I
swear to God I get them from Chewie they
smell like like I said they smell like
mint and they look like a little it's
like a little soft bar with like little
mint leaves on the end
and she likes to pick him up with one
hand and she's like
she just like rubs him all over her face
it's like hilarious
Zach says I like things that are spicy
but not stupidly spicy because I still
like being able to taste what I'm eating
especially meat yeah me too it's like I
like a little bit of spice and flavor
and stuff but it's like if it's too much
spice and that's all that I can taste
then I'm not really into that you know I
don't know I like it sometimes I know
you do I know you do yeah but after a
while like and like I said the older I
get like the more my digestive system is
just kind of like nope not having it
um
you guys like we were at the bar earlier
I was like
because you know Thanksgiving is coming
up this week which I'm excited about
yeah we have literally six six turkeys
they were cheap we have six turkeys
Publix had a sale yeah where went down
got a bunch of
they were 49 cents a pound yeah like but
you could only buy two like the smaller
ones yeah like they have like a deal so
like we went down there like separately
at a time I like to bought two at a time
yeah because I really like turkeys and I
was like well we could freeze those and
we could eat those later I got a [ __ ]
ton of turkeys
we have six turkeys they're not like
they're not giant but we did get some
smaller ones I think the one that I got
well the ones that I bought
I didn't see the ones that you picked up
because like I said they're the same as
yours yeah I think they were like
the one I bought was the one of them was
six dollars and 11 cents and one of them
was five dollars and 45 cents or
something like that so it's just kind of
like
so what were they that's well actually
that's not because if there were 49
cents a pound that's probably like what
like 10 pounds right 10 11 pounds they
were five dollars each essentially yeah
they were all of the turkeys that they
had were like between like 350 and 650
like all of them and they weren't
massive they were like 10 pounds or
something like that but I was just like
twice the size of a chicken
easily and I love turkey like I said I
don't I know some people like don't
really
you know they like Thanksgiving at the
time but then they're like yeah I'm kind
of sick of turkey I never get sick of
turkey I love [ __ ] turkey I like
turkey better than chicken I like
chicken too but man I could eat
Thanksgiving probably every day and
never get tired of it
it's a turkey man it's [ __ ] knife
it's not even [ __ ] funny I mean
yeah plus you bought all those pumpkins
from yeah from the pumpkin patch I got
six pumpkins yeah yeah that's how I'm
gonna do it well I mean
I mean yeah I mean you need a whole
turkey that you can just make sandwiches
out of too because turkeys that also
yeah I mean you could just make a whole
turkey and I'll just make sandwiches
with it oh man
American Military 100 said I suffered
through Steven Seagal's The Foreigner I
swear that guy's filmography in a
nutshell should read his worst movie
since his last
hahaha
that's just funny for example
the foreigner like what I would be
curious like what is what was the um
what was the premise of that was he the
Foreigner or was there someone who was
the bad guy who's the Foreigner which I
suspect is probably the
the thing behind it I'm trying to
imagine right now
I'm trying to explain it
yeah clearly
um Stephen skull
he was in those days that she was
supposed to be very mainstream okay it
wasn't supposed to be a meme or some
crazy [ __ ] it was mainstream
entertainment
well that's his own fault that that
happens yeah
just saying a good restroom just saved
yeah
man I can't understand [ __ ] Steve
Segal I don't either I don't I don't
really get it either
are the Foreigner it's an experience now
I want to watch it I mean not really but
kind of you know what I mean maybe I'll
kind of like watch it while I'm doing
something else I don't want to feel like
I wasted all my time but I kind of want
to see it though
uh Tom and Jenny said will you name them
all Steven Seagal who the turkeys yeah
we could if I mean if you'd like that if
you like that yeah we we can name them
all that
Zach says uh when it's Thanksgiving I
always go after the ham the way my
parents always made turkey was always
like eating damp cardboard I love turkey
as lunch meat though that's kind of a
shame because I feel like that happens
so much like back in the old days there
was this whole thing about it's like oh
they overcooked the turkey and it was
like super dry I have literally never
and I've made Thanksgiving dinners
myself like just when I lived alone
um you know with my family and then you
know with Tom and stuff making them I
have literally never had a turkey that
was true too dry like they were always
good so
I kind of feel like people are just like
cooking them too long is probably the
problem
honestly and two like I'm a big dark
meat fan too which the breast has a
tendency to maybe get a little bit drier
if you overcook it but like the dark
meat ever does but the way we cook it
I've never had that issue I just think
people are cooking it too long I think
uh Senor stick says Jenny goose and
lobster is traditional on Thanksgiving
I'll take the lobster thanks I don't
think I've ever had Goose though not
that I can think of but I love Lobster
and
Rebecca said what was his accent
that's a good question now now I'm
uh the four is the foreign escapes from
a Chinese prison
Hugo says uh capriati's has turkey
Thanksgiving sandwich all year long with
stuffing and everything pretty good yeah
see I love that kind of [ __ ] I honestly
like I love like the whole Thanksgiving
meal
but
everybody knows the best [ __ ] about it
is having the sandwiches and stuff the
next day like you put the sandwich you
put the you put mayo you put stuffing on
it you put maybe put some cranberry on
there if you're into that kind of stuff
and it's like man that's like so good so
good I feel like some [ __ ] crusty ass
bread
man I'm making myself hungry I can't
believe it's Thanksgiving already holy
[ __ ] it seemed like it was just
Halloween and then we were in the biker
bar and I was like watching the TVs and
it's like they have all the Christmas
commercials on now and I'm like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] man it's gonna be like
Christmas and
like a month or like six weeks something
like that and I was like how can it be
[ __ ] Christmas already it was just
Halloween
God damn
time is moving too quickly for me
murder Hornet said might go to Florida
to see my parents for Thanksgiving
that's cool
I know we're talking about I know Danny
Rowling keeps bringing up blood rage
I put it in the poll for this week if it
doesn't win then maybe we'll do it like
as a matinee although I
to be honest with you we already have
the movie set up that we're gonna do
this week for matinee because they're
more you like Universal movies we've
already watched them we've already
watched them
is Steven Seagal an American hero maybe
uh no
he probably thinks of himself no he
isn't
he probably thinks that his office that
[ __ ] is tripping okay
John Smith said
I had a Thanksgiving dinner when I
visited the US and my host said
marshmallows in the mashed potatoes
which kind of summed up the US for me
hopefully they didn't put marshmallows
in like the mashed potatoes like I've
seen marshmallows in sweet potatoes
which I'm not a fan of I have to say
um I don't like marshmallows generally
but a lot of people do
the marshmallows and sweet potatoes
thing which I don't I don't love that
mashed potatoes that [ __ ] better be
unadulterated other than butter and salt
and pepper I don't want anything else in
my [ __ ] mashed potatoes yeah
no I that must have been that sweet
potato thing but like I said I don't
really like that but a lot of people do
that I don't get it but
hey if some people like that all right
all right
yeah Senor stick said the pilgrims had
Lobster and turkey yeah
Lobster Lobster
murder Hornet said I make gravy for
biscuits with turkey juice
Tom was trained by count Dante yeah yeah
definitely who said that murder Hornet
yeah yeah of course
and also uh giblet gravy yeah you if so
Tom makes that pretty much every year I
love it he makes two different you make
gravy with the vegetables with just the
vet like the leftover vegetable like the
celery tops and all that kind of stuff
and then he makes one with like the the
stuff that you take out of the turkey
like the liver and the neck and
everything
yeah man I'm [ __ ] up yeah you are I am
I've been drinking all day
I couldn't help it you couldn't help it
I couldn't help it
are you gonna like contribute to the to
the shower now no probably not
what time is it
we've been on for like less than an hour
less than an hour yeah I can contribute
sometime or another thank you yeah I
would appreciate it I gotta kind of like
[ __ ] like wake myself up yeah you
should yeah we can talk about food you
know I'm not going like I'm [ __ ]
zooming in and out of this well [ __ ] man
like even when I got there yeah I got
there at like what was it quarter it was
quarter to four yeah I remember it was
like quarter to four
um even when I got there he was already
kind of [ __ ] up when I got there yeah
they were egging me on
and you just said it were what if
everybody jumped off a bridge with you
yeah stop it like a mom says
yeah the whole bar eggs me on
making you drink more yeah you're so
susceptible to outside influences Tom
yeah
John Smith said Thomas to Center himself
yeah yeah I'm saying murder Hornet says
Coffee
maybe maybe you should make some coffee
I just I just ground some beans no
they're in there pissing my brains out
if I were if I were to drink you do that
anyway no
I'm not doing anything I just ground up
some fresh beans and put them in the can
you can like make a cup right there go
ahead and go on all right what are they
saying Zach says sweet potatoes is
something that I always think I'm gonna
like when I try it but something that
the flavor doesn't do it for me I like
them in some applications I mean
honestly
as far as the Thanksgiving thing goes
like I said a lot of people do that
whole like marshmallow thing which I'm
not into that I don't really like
marshmallows
um I do like sweet potato I like sweet
potato fries but if you're gonna do
potatoes I would rather just regular
potatoes I'm more like a mashed potato
just regular Idaho potatoes kind of
thing but I'll eat sweet potatoes
they're all good I mean you know I like
them all
and I'm gonna like maybe this is a
controversial statement too because I
know a lot of people in the U.S will be
like oh green bean casserole I don't
really like green bean casserole
I like green bean casserole also
Jenny Jenny's talking [ __ ] about all
this I love it I'm not well I'll eat it
it's just that's good look there's only
so much stomach space that you have you
have to economize when Thanksgiving
because look there's only so much space
in there it's like I can't fit all the
things because I'll throw up
oh man the corn okay now see I'm into
that I like that like you always make
Tom always makes for Thanksgiving he
always makes that Brazilian like cream
corn which we put in um which we put in
the cookbook and that is delicious yeah
that's delicious that's it and I like
cream corn because just regularly but
the Brazilian one that's like way way
better
so I do like that but I'm just saying
that a lot of people like that very
classic mid-century
green bean casserole with like the fried
like the crispy fried onions on top I
don't love that like it's okay if
somebody said hey you have to eat it
I'll eat it but I would rather save the
space for other things that I like
better
not real into like uh cranberry sauce
either
I don't mind a little bit but I like it
I kind of feel like because when I grew
up it was just kind of like everybody
was like canned cranberries so they just
like dump it out the can and then slice
it up and they're like [ __ ] it which
like the cranberry gel yeah like I
wasn't really into that that's very
basic it is yeah yeah even fresh
cranberry it's good like a little bit
like I like it better the next day like
when you put it on the sandwich but just
a little bit
like just to give it that tartness you
know what I mean yeah
Rebecca says mashed potatoes or potatoes
au gratin please yeah that works too
that works too sweet potatoes are fine
but it's like it's not my favorite I
would rather just have mashed potatoes
or potatoes our garden is good too
Dave really said that's not cranberry
sauce murder Hornet said deviled eggs
also good you know what that's one of
those things that I didn't like as a kid
I don't know what I was thinking I
didn't like deviled eggs as a kid but I
really
I really really like got an appreciation
for them later on it was kind of one of
those things where
when I was a child like here's the thing
when I was a child I was a really picky
eater
um I didn't like anything like I didn't
like tomatoes I didn't like mushrooms I
didn't like anything like that which is
crazy because now tomatoes and mushrooms
are two of my absolute favorite foods
but
there's that to you you know
and deviled eggs like I liked every
other kind of eggs but for whatever
reason when I was a kid like hard-boiled
or deviled eggs I was just kind of like
ooh that was like beyond the pail but I
don't know why I was like that
when I got older I was just kind of like
what am I talking about this shit's
delicious Zach said I think my favorite
kind of regular potato fries is the kind
where the thinly closed uh thinly close
rounds that are deep fried I mean I
honestly I'll eat any kind of potatoes
if you're talking about French fries I
like
um I don't know if anybody still does
these anymore but for a long time back
in I want to say like the 80s or the 90s
KFC used to have this big wedge french
fries that still have the skin on them
um that were like triangular shaped and
they were like really big and stuff and
I was like yeah I was really into those
um but I'll eat any kind of all kind of
french fries are good but I like the
ones that are like real potato heavy you
know
Senora stick says uh will you make
deviled eggs and turkey for the biker
bar Chase up you're gonna take some like
uh [ __ ] Thanksgiving dinner down to
the biker bar no
[Laughter]
no we're not gonna worry about them
We're Not Gonna worry about them no okay
not at all
because you give them something that the
numbers will multiply
then the next thing you know they're at
your house ask it for more no we're not
gonna worry about it
yeah you don't want to like feed them
they'll like keep coming back every year
murder one had said some reason we eat
black olives on Thanksgiving
yeah I mean when I was growing up one of
the things that was real big was like
your kind of pickle tray
you know and you'd have the pickle tray
like my grandmother like I like sour
pickles and that's pretty much the
extent of it like some people like sweet
pickles which I don't and then there
were like kind of like olives and stuff
on there too
and
I don't know I get some people like
olives I don't really like black olives
you like black olives you like pizza
with black olives yeah I like them [ __ ]
man he used to like go to Sam's and buy
like the big cans of black olives and
like put them on Pizza I'm not I don't
hate them but it's not really
I don't know it's not really my thing
they're too salty no
salty no I don't think I don't know what
it is they're salty they're kind of sour
it's just kind of like I don't know I'm
not I'm not really into it I'm not
really into it I'm not really into
olives I like pickles but I like sour
pickles I don't like the sweet pickles
that's shit's gross
Jeffy Hart said my mom makes smashed
turnips with potatoes carrots cream salt
pepper and you guessed it butter and
she'll whip it until it's light and
fluffy that actually sounds
delicious gonna say I would eat that
Zach said I also really love potato
wedges and KFC still does those I'm
pretty sure I wouldn't know because I
haven't been to KFC in a really long
time so I don't know if they still have
those but I remember
that they used to have those
Tom
passing out why are you doing this why
are you being this way
who's calling me nobody I'm calling you
said Tom never yeah that was me saying
your name yeah and I was like why are
you being this way not being a certain
way yeah you are man I'm passing out hmm
okay how much did you drink before I got
there you knew you had to do the show
today
you knew you had to do the show today
yeah
you didn't care though clearly
it's just one thing after another I'm
not worried about anything I'm just like
yeah that's what happened
yeah that's what happened that's what
happened yeah okay
yeah
come on what get your [ __ ] together no I
can't get your [ __ ] together I can't
Senor stick says deviled eggs you have
to make well yeah uh Rebecca said KFC
fries are covered in chicken Salt here
um salt what's cheese salt well I
imagine imagine if it's like chicken
with like chicken broth flavor that's
right well there's nothing wrong with
chicken Salt
that's gross it's not gross that's not
gross okay
uh Jeffy heart said KFC still makes the
wedges okay well my I have to I might
have to go back there and investigate I
haven't gotten any food from KFC since I
don't even remember when that was
because my um
my uncle used to own a KFC franchise in
the Daytona Beach area
so we always used to get KFC all the
time like when I was growing up and like
my mom and dad both worked managing
KFC's at various times during my
childhood so we had a lot of KFC back
then but I haven't really like eaten
there
more recently so I don't like know what
their menu is like nowadays
uh and Hugo says I like Popeye's mashed
potatoes over KFC's have I
when did we we got Popeyes not too long
ago right yeah
did I get mashed potatoes from there I
don't know honestly of all the fast food
not not enough fast food places do
mashed potatoes one of all the mashed
potato places like Boston Market it's
got the best mashed potatoes gonna have
to say Boston Market and that's like
more fast casual it's not really fast
food because I don't think it has a
drive through but
gonna say if you're gonna get mashed
potatoes I would advise getting them
from Boston Market they got really
really good mashed potatoes
other ones are good too like it's hard
to mesh it mess up mashed potatoes but
you know
um and Zach says I've also become
addicted to rotisserie chickens lately
the kind they sell at Walmart are basic
as [ __ ] but so good honestly I love that
so many stores because it's not just
Walmart it's like pretty much anywhere
you can get a rotisserie chicken for
really not that expensive I don't know
how much they're selling them for
nowadays I think like Sam's and Costco I
think they're what like 5.99 and 600 and
something like that maybe Walmart is the
same and maybe like for a buck or two
more you can get them like from a
fancier store but you can not only just
like eat those as they are but you can
use them in like so many other [ __ ]
recipes too it's like really really cost
effective
and you don't have to cook it like at
your own house you can put that [ __ ] on
tacos you can do all kind of stuff with
it
seriously
Tammy said you are right
who you yeah
you're not Tammy said are you all right
yeah no I said you're all right I asked
if you were all right what's it gonna do
with Tammy nothing I was like I was
starting to read her comments and then I
looked at you and you looked like you
were fading out I am I'm fading like a
[ __ ] but I'm I'm holding on
really yeah this is you're really not
like giving the people I'm giving the
people anything worth I'm giving the
people
you're not
look at you Tom
look at you
yeah okay don't happen look at me look
at you okay
I'm having fun Danny Rowling said Tom
transformed into dancing with the black
wig
they're trying to get me to transform
and [ __ ] I can't do it man I mean you
seem like this is about the time
although you might be like past that
point yeah give it a pass I will say
that at the biker bar he did when one of
the James Bond themes was on he did go
and like dance on the pole I was dancing
on the pole yeah yeah yeah I mean not
that many people were there but yeah he
was dancing like as the [ __ ] yeah
they were looking
and they're like yeah look at that drunk
ass [ __ ] in the afternoon the
women were looking
yeah you didn't see no I saw it okay
yeah he's trying to make me jealous I'm
not trying to make her jealous but I
don't really care she's no so she don't
care no well because well because it's
really transparent they're just like hey
other women were looking at me while I
was like up on the
on the pole and I was just like okay
I know you want me to get mad but I'm
not mad I'm just sleeping
why are you being the Dopey this way
Friday night it's Friday night come on
have a good time just knocking me out
have a good time have a good time
uh Tammy said my grandma used to make
homemade fruit salad every big holiday I
kind of feel like
didn't everybody I was reading an
article the other day
I kind of feel like in most of the US
they call that Ambrosia right ambrosia
salad which is kind of like the fruit
that you got out of the cans yeah like
the Mandarin oranges and like the
coconut sometimes and Cool Whip and [ __ ]
like that
um some people call it uh other names
like I've heard it called green stuff or
frog eye salad I've heard that it sounds
but yeah I think most States call it
Ambrosia but it's the same kind of thing
it's the same kind of thing my
grandparents made that to you like
everybody made that and like brought it
Senora stick says so Jenny no anchovies
for you then as you don't like salt no I
mean it's not so much that I'm not like
I like salt to a degree but I do kind of
feel like olives are like way like over
salty same thing about anchovies I don't
mind anchovies if they're like in
because I know like some Italian
dressings and stuff like have anchovies
in there and that's fine but it's like I
don't really want like anchovies on my
pizza or so because I kind of feel like
it overwhelms like all the other flavors
granther said this is classic LOL
see this is what happens he goes out and
drinks all day oh stop it and then comes
back and then he's like I can't
Tammy said I'm just waiting for Tom to
slide off the chair yeah yeah
but if I if I push you like that will
you no no
[Laughter]
body wants to pick on me and [ __ ]
because well because it's funny it's
funny and it's easy because you're just
like swaying around I haven't been
[ __ ] drinking or anything man if the
trick is right look if I was like if I
was as drunk as you are right now which
you know I'm pretty drunk too I'm not
saying but it's like if I was as drunk
as you are right now where I couldn't
even like talk or like handle my [ __ ]
everybody making fun of me too including
you so no yeah yeah I'm afraid so no so
you just gotta [ __ ] take it you gotta
[ __ ] take it I'm good you gotta take
it just like everybody else does I'm
good
okay Rebecca says holy [ __ ] basic as
[ __ ] rotisserie chicken is like 14
including the exchange rate Australia's
expensive as [ __ ] I mean it depends on
where you go I kind of and I haven't
been for a long time but because I think
Publix is more expensive right like if
you buy a rotisserie chicken there
especially it's like a flavored one
I think the ones at Publix are Maybe
I want to say 6.99 7.99 something like
that but I think that Walmart Costco
Sam's kind of your more like Club type
places
um I think you can get them for five or
six dollars
a rotisserie chicken I think or used to
be able to I don't know about nowadays
we got a raw turkey for five dollars
each
for a turkey
yeah I mean well like I said Publix
which are slightly more expensive but
their quality is like better and I don't
think they're as expensive as they used
to be perceived as because I kind of
feel like when I was growing up everyone
perceived oh Publix that's the fancy
grocery store and that was like way more
than the more working class store which
was Winn-Dixie where I grew up
but
I kind of feel like they're not really
that much more expensive they're turkeys
like I said were they were selling them
for 49 cents a pound it was a limited
time like only until last yesterday was
the last day right yesterday was the
last day that's why we went yesterday
and we're like oh we gotta get some more
because I love turkey so yeah 49 cents a
pound but they were selling off like
this they had this kind of like um like
an end cap that had like a bunch of
smaller turkeys that were like you know
eight nine ten-ish pounds and they were
selling those off for 49 cents a pound
so but you can only buy two like one
person could only buy two so we went in
there separate
like over a couple of times and bought
like seven so now we have six of them so
that's why uh senior stick says Tom
nursing a hangover yet he's been at the
biker barley drinking all day
uh so there's that
Zach says my grandma used to make
pineapple fluffy it was basically a kind
of fruit salad but with pineapple
marshmallow whipped cream on it yeah my
grandma made that too my grandma made
that too well
I kind of feel like that's like that's a
Southern and
Midwestern thing maybe it was other
parts of the country too but I kind of
feel like that was I always perceived
that as like more of a Southern and
Midwestern thing but
you know where you like would pour a
bunch of like fruit out of cans like
fruit salad or pineapple chunks or
whatever the hell and like you'd mix it
with Cool Whip sometimes like the sugar
or like the um the sweetened like
coconut flakes that kind of stuff and
you'd like mix sometimes with mayonnaise
but that was a little weird so I don't
think my grandma did that but
yeah that was a big thing you'd always
have like at holidays and I'm trying to
think of and like like I said she always
did a pickle tray which always had sour
pickle sweet pickles and then olives I
don't think she did black olives well
maybe she did but she did like regular
green olives which I never ate those but
because [ __ ] that and then she'd always
do like a hard-boiled egg or a deviled
egg tray
so you'd have that at every holiday it
was she usually did Thanksgiving and
Christmas
and what else
I think I put in the cookbook she always
would make gooey butter cake which I've
also heard it called ooey gooey butter
cake it's the same thing though but it's
one of those things where it's kind of
like you know um
the thing that they call like semi-home
made where you know you take like for
example like a boxed cake mix and mix it
with like real ingredients and then like
make it that's kind of like that so you
take like boxed cake mix but you'd mix
it with what up what the [ __ ] was in
there like cream cheese like for like 40
bajillion tons of butter uh you know and
like a bunch of other stuff and it was
like really really good but it's it's
super rich
and you could really only have one about
one piece a year because because it was
like that much
uh Senor stick said Tom and Jerry do you
have any seasonal fruit cake ready for
the holidays I'm not super into
fruitcake like I'll eat it but
if I'm gonna like eat those calories I
would rather have something that was not
fruitcake you know what I'm saying
I don't know
if I'm gonna eat cake I would rather
have it be like I said I'm not I like
chocolate cake but it's not my favorite
thing I honestly like
stuff like yellow cake vanilla cake or
coconut cake or
I don't know just something with
something like nuts or hazelnut or
something I don't know
Tammy said uh no my grammy is fresh
oranges grapefruit apples grapes at the
time of Summer slice him some banana
okay so that actually sounds good
Rebecca said I miss public so much
nothing like that Supermarket here yeah
I kind of forget because I don't know I
mean Publix that's
that's a southern thing I kind of feel
like I the headquarters I think are in
Florida someplace maybe Clearwater
I want to say I can't even remember
where the headquarters is but I think
Publix is headquartered in Florida but I
think it's just like a southern thing
but for whatever reason like Publix is
just a really really good
supermarket and they've always been like
that like as long as I can remember like
back from when I was a kid that was like
the fancy supermarket
what
yeah the Fan's on I know it's on
she's telling us the bands on
we know sweetie we know
but um
I don't know what it is it's like
they're not all that different from like
a regular grocery store like especially
nowadays because now that everybody else
is kind of like caught up like even when
Dixie and stuff like that which is kind
of like a little bit ghetto when I was
growing out y'all are catching up to us
but everybody's like catching up so
everybody because you can't
nowadays everybody's like a lot more
savvy so you can't get away with being
shitty anymore because there's too much
competition you know I'm just saying so
um so Publix doesn't have maybe the edge
that it used to have but the thing about
it is that and I've had like a lot of
relatives that worked for Publix also
and they're like one they're a really
good place to work for like um you know
they're really really good to their
employees and employees tend to stay
there for a long time which is a good
sign but they really seem to prioritize
just the quality of stuff like
particularly they're Deli and their
Bakery which is kind of what they're
known for like I said they're sub
sandwiches like if you go there to the
deli and like get a sub sandwich are
Exquisite like you will never get like a
better sub sandwich anywhere than their
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is like so good and I
can't even explain like why what the
difference is
like if you went to Subway and then you
went to got in public Public Sub there
was like a [ __ ] million years of
difference between those two things even
though they're both like a sandwich
that's that's cold and it's on like
regular bread and [ __ ] but
it's like a huge huge difference
but you know and their bakery is awesome
too we get like pretty much every cake
for every
event like anyone's birthday or anything
like that anytime we'd like we need to
order a cake we always get it from
Publix and it's always been fantastic
always
um Kevin is giving us hearts and saying
hello
uh Danny Rowling said Primo's Hoagies
are the best in my opinion I've never
had them though so I don't really know
but like I said in if you're in Florida
like pretty much everybody knows that
Publix uh Subs are the best subs
better than pretty much anybody
and I've had like some pretty you know
I've had good Subs like other places
like Jimmy John's and [ __ ] like that but
they make good stuff too but I don't
know public Subs are just like better
and I don't really know why
Zach said she also used to make wedding
cookies you know the round balls of the
powdered sugar and the nuts inside my
grandma used to make those too she used
to put them in her um Christmas bag my
grandma used to like before she was in
her 90s and had had a stroke
but she used to
um make a bajillion different kind of
Christmas cookies and she would put like
all different kinds in people's bags and
she'd give them to everybody because she
had
she had eight kids
uh who all had multiple children so she
had many many children and many many
grandchildren so she would make like all
these bags of cookies every year for
everybody which was amazing because I
can't even imagine how much work went
into that
um you know all the varieties that she
made and she that was one of the things
she would make she would make wedding
cookies and actually I really really
love those I really like those
Danny Rowling said the 2001 film uh
Route 666 starring Lou Diamond Phillips
Dale Midkiff who was in uh the original
pet cemetery and Lori Petty who is
intent girl is an underrated ghost
zombie film just saying
um
did I ever see that
that kind of seems like something I
would have seen if I did see it I don't
remember it
but
if you remind me I'll I will look it up
at some point I'll look it up at some
point
Lou Diamond Phillips he was in that
[ __ ] he's doing a bunch of [ __ ] well
he was in a bunch of [ __ ] he was in La
Bamba I remember that
I remember it being a little bomb but
because I saw that in the [ __ ] uh
theater but he was in that Satanist
movie that we saw remember we reviewed
that not sure what the [ __ ] the fifth or
yeah the first Power the first first
power first Power second power third
power whatever
no uh Tammy said I make fluff using
crushed pineapple whole cranberry sauce
and Cool Whip sounds gross but it's
really it doesn't sound gross that
actually sounds pretty good
well that's yeah that's that's what I've
heard that called that a lot of us have
like pineapple fluff or
I knew it as ambrosia I mean we called
it Ambrosia but well the thing about it
like what we call Ambrosia is that
really the same thing as pineapple fluff
though because it's similar
it's something that like you mix
together with like fruit whether fresh
or canned or whatever and you like mixed
it together with Cool Whip or
sour cream or not sour cream or cream
cheese or something and then you would
put like coconut flakes in it yeah it
was like that kind of or marshmallows
sometimes like that kind of stuff like
you'd kind of whip it it's good I'm not
saying that I'm just saying that it's
kind of the same thing but they have the
same it has different names like all
across the country
Rebecca says Publix cheeses and meats
are high quality yeah that's the thing I
think they really as I said they've kind
of Pride themselves on
everything being
kind of like top of the line and
especially like their Deli is very well
regarded and their Bakery is well
regarded because they
like I said they really seem to like
Pride themselves on making the best
possible [ __ ] that they can make like
whether it's sandwiches or fried chicken
or whatever or whether it's their Bakery
with like cakes we have gotten many many
cakes from there I've gotten my last
several years of birthday cakes there
we've gotten your last several years of
birthday cakes there and every single
cake that comes out of that Bakery is
amazing and actually I have a friend
that works that works for their Bakery
for like a really long time so they do
like actually like hire people that are
you know really really like [ __ ] into
like baking [ __ ] and like decorating and
stuff like that so but all of them are
like super super good
and let's see they're talking about
young Gods yeah the first Power
um
yeah Tammy's asking Danny rolling where
are you at I don't know too many people
call them Hoagies
and know about their Giant grocery
stores yeah I kind of feel like Hoagies
that's more of like a it's Midwest
yeah that's a Midwest or upper Detroit
Li yeah that's like that kind of yeah
down here they call them Subs it's the
same thing it's the same thing
I've seen them called Hoagies if you
call it a hoagie like I don't think
anybody's gonna look at you like what
does that mean like everybody knows what
that word means but
now if you called it a grinder
then people might wonder what you were
talking about but I have heard them
called that although I think that's
maybe that's a Pennsylvania thing isn't
it calling them Grinders I don't know if
you said grinder nowadays people would
think you were talking about that that
hookup site
game hookup site the gay hookup site
yeah yeah with without the e sex his
face is painted all over that [ __ ]
a liver grinder yeah
foreign
said uh Route 666 is about a haunted
closed Highway
uh by a ghostly Chain Gang that died
horrifically on the road see uh okay
that sounds good I'm gonna look that up
uh Zach says also
I don't know okay I don't know if you
meant to say Lord but it says Lord Lord
is the job market
oh Lord is Lord comma is the job market
at pain I've been looking at remote
editing jobs but even those require
Bachelor Bachelor's in editing like what
the [ __ ] yeah I mean you know it's
things are tough all over
uh Zach says also I'm from Indiana and
I've never heard them called Hoagies
outside of TV yeah down here the
preferred nomenclature is Subs it's a
sub sandwich
um if you said Hoagie people would maybe
look at you like Mer but they would know
what you were talking about but like I
said if you called it like a grinder
or something like people might look at
you weird then but
I kind of feel like most people just say
sub right it's just a sub sandwich yeah
I kind of feel like that's the preferred
nomenclature down here
Louie says call it a night Tom never
seen Tom the space yeah yeah I'm [ __ ]
faded like a [ __ ] I mean I can't
believe like that you did this I can't
believe this I have to stay here
I won't let you yeah she won't let me
figure well I told you earlier yeah it's
like you know we have to do the show
later I'm good
you're not though obviously
you're not
you're not obviously
Danny rolling said Hoagies is an East
Coast thing just like uh water ice like
water ice
yeah that's
um I think I know what you're talking
about but not entirely sure not entirely
sure
um let's see
it's actually it's the only way Tom
knows is
if he's on there too Glenn says Jen give
him a break
I would but um no because I'm used to
look I've known you for like more than
11 years at this point is this not gonna
happen and it's like I know how you do
and it's like I tell you look we have to
do a show later yeah like don't get too
[ __ ] up and then like you proceed to
get too [ __ ] up no
and then I'm like wow I'm not too [ __ ]
up
obviously you are though because you're
like just like falling asleep no I'm
here I'm here watching the show okay are
you yeah you're not contributing though
you're on the shower
no I'm just telling you it's like you're
on the show I'll leave the show and fall
asleep you're on the show oh yeah I'm on
it I'm on it
[Laughter]
it's it's [ __ ] Saturday man it's
Friday
Friday it's Saturday I don't even know
what it is that Saturday it's Friday
though it's Friday it's Friday oh my God
the show's almost over anyway no it's
not what time is it it's all we've only
been on an hour yeah it's only seven
o'clock that's it right there it is
good now
seriously it's good enough
seriously Tom
oh my God what
Zach says my issue with getting drunk is
uh I get drunk real fast because I'm a
lightweight but I also sober up real
fast so I have to spend the night buying
beers when I want to party um
um yeah
I don't know I don't get drunk
particularly fast but sometimes it kind
of like
the weird thing is like sometimes
they'll be like not drunk not drunk not
drunk not drunk and then suddenly very
very drunk so it's just kind of like a
thing where
I feel okay for a really long time but
then suddenly I'm like I'm like oh well
I'm super [ __ ] up now it's kind of
that kind of thing
Louie says same in La we've always
called them Subs
yeah I kind of feel like most people
where we live it's always subs right
I've heard it called other things I know
that but it's like we've always called
themselves come here
please [ __ ] [ __ ] with me what's
she doing trying to get me to [ __ ]
play oh
she was late she was down there like
laying playing with her my teeth look at
her butt look at her butt
she's like nope she doesn't trust you
she trust me she wasn't gonna put a
wrestle with her though big time come
here can you guys see her yeah you guys
can see her she's like I'm not I'm not
sure about this situation I'm not sure
Jesus playing
so then you want to come you want to
come [ __ ] with me okay come here
just say no no no
[Laughter]
he's funny
granther says is mannequins on the
agenda after the show ends no uh no no
we're not going out this weekend
probably well because we've been out the
last couple weekends and I was like dude
I'm like [ __ ] broke as [ __ ] it's just
like and honestly
next Friday
next Friday right the Friday after
Thanksgiving yeah because Thanksgiving
is holy [ __ ] Thanksgiving is this week
um
the Friday after Thanksgiving they're
doing a Memento Mori so we gotta go to
that so it'll be like Friday night but
so this week and I'm like dude I was
like one I'm broke as [ __ ] I really
don't need to go out this weekend I
really don't I mean I like to but come
here
one it takes me like one or two days to
recover come here two
can't really afford it so you know
there's that come here
but
so I was like no I'm not messing with
her come here poop come here Pookie
doesn't trust you
no no
she knows she knows your game Tom yeah
she knows I'm I'm a biter
come here why are you gonna bite her
don't bite her
okay
she's looking at you like we're good
[ __ ] funny pokey's not dumb I'm
telling you right now yeah she's funny
she is one of the smartest cats that
I've ever
and I'm not saying like cats are smart
okay like I know a lot of people like I
know they haven't done like a lot of
research on that and [ __ ] like that but
I think they've done more research on
dogs but
cats are smart she knows
um
she knows the meaning of several words
and phrases she knows what come here
means she knows her name she knows what
she knows what treats means yeah she
knows what meat sticks means she knows
what jump down means she knows what what
I mean she knows what some words mean so
much that we've had to spell them
because like if you say them out loud
she's like we're like you know what I
mean so
and she also knows
when you're acting [ __ ] up like you
are right now
she also knows when you're acting [ __ ]
up and she's just kind of like
you know what she did this morning
I don't think I told you
um we have a little plate in our room
that has like treats on it that she can
kind of Nosh on like during the night if
she would like to
sometimes we forget to put treats on it
before we go to sleep
and if we forget to do that like
sometimes it'll be like two three
o'clock in the morning and you'll be
sleeping and all of a sudden you'll feel
a little little pause just tapping on
your chest or some part of your body
they'll be waking you up this morning at
four or five in the morning I felt a
little bitty paw on my foot
boop boop boop like that La five in the
morning and I woke up and I saw her like
standing at the end of the bed going
on my foot use food and then like I woke
up and I saw that her plate like she
didn't have any treats on her plate and
I was like oh she didn't like jump on my
face right she's very polite yeah
um she just jumped up on the edge of the
bed and was like please please
yeah she was just like tapping on my
foot just on my foot which was sticking
out in front of the cover she was like
poop
and I was like oh my God she was like so
[ __ ] cute so I got up and like put
some [ __ ] treats on there but that's
what she wanted because I'm gonna put oh
poor baby poor baby come here
come here no no no no no I'll trust you
I don't trust you she knows your [ __ ]
yeah she knows I'm drinking yeah no I
don't trust well like I said sometimes
if we come home from the bar and we're
like super [ __ ] up like Pookie will be
like she'll look at us and be like wow
we're glad I'm glad you're home but I'm
just gonna go in here bye you know what
I mean you guys are drunk yeah she knows
she knows uh Zach says I'm probably
moving in with my boyfriend in May and I
kind of want to get a pet can't decide
if it's a cat or a dog I can't choose
are there any wines you guys like
um oh that was random I don't know I'm
not like wines I'm not like a real big
wine connoisseur like we mostly just
drink like vodka and [ __ ] like that and
tequila so I don't know about wines
it seems like something I kind of want
to get into but I just never have
as far as like cats or dogs it depends
on what you want
um
I'm I'm more a cat person I'm gonna say
than a dog person I think the reason
that I'm not a dog person is because
dogs are more high maintenance it's more
like having an actual kid
um you know they're very uh you know
attention starved they're very needy
stuff like that that said
um it depends on what kind of cat you
get because Pookie is
while perhaps not as attention starved
as a dog is pretty centered around
attention when she's not sleeping she
will absolutely like jump on your
keyboard when you're trying to type or
you know want to be like want to be
brushed like you know she'll jump on
your [ __ ] and be like yell until you go
over there and pay attention so she is
kind of like attention hungry too
but
you don't I mean on the plus side she
doesn't really care about going outside
you don't have to like take her out for
a walk or anything like that she sleeps
most of the time but she is a little bit
high maintenance work at but it does
actually depend on what
breed you get too I think
because that Pookie is a Manx and manks
are typically more
dog-like than other cat breeds
uh they tend to be a little bit more
high maintenance than a cat normally
would be
but
in general I kind of feel like cats are
less maintenance than a dog
you know yeah definitely
but you still have to pay it that's not
like a thing where you can just like
ignore them because you can't
I mean that's not gonna work out that's
not gonna work out you still got to pay
attention to them but
it depends on how much interaction you
want from it
it depends on how much interaction you
want
you know yeah what time is it
dude it's 7 17. damn Shirley yeah it's
early yeah it's
Louis says Jenny have you heard of
Terence Williams and Felipe Santos they
disappeared in 2003 and 2004 in Naples
Florida they were last seen with the
same deputy sheriff I've heard those
names but I don't really know a lot
about those cases but I should probably
like look that up because yeah that does
sound like something like that I read
about before but you know
um Daniel Rowling said Tom should put on
the Bane mask
[Laughter]
maybe you should no do drunk for Bane
you're too drunk for Bane you're too
drunk for everything evidently I'm not
gonna last much longer actually I guess
not I mean
you're kind of bumming me out Tom kind
of bumming me out
I even went down to the biker bar
because you wanted me to go down to the
biker Barn
and now like you're just falling asleep
and
can't even talk no
no
oh my goodness
oh my goodness
this is the worst I've never seen you
this bad I've never seen you this bad
well at least not on the show I've seen
you this bad in like real life before
but I've never seen it as bad I'm trying
to hold it together
yeah okay yeah I'm letting you do the
show do the show yeah but most of the
fun of the Friday night show is like
interaction and you're not interacting
you're just kind of like laying there
Danny rolling said a Monster energy
drink would wake you up do you have any
aren't there some in the fridge it's not
a monster it's a uh what is it it's an
energy from Dollars Dollar General well
that's like it's probably the same [ __ ]
Go Get It Go Get It I thought you had
some in the door I got like three of
them yeah I thought you did yeah
I was gonna say I thought he had some I
was in there getting my coffee creamer
out earlier and I was like oh he bought
some
energy drinks from the dollar store I
don't drink those because they taste
like ass but you know what I mean he
likes them
Tom in the doghouse tomorrow he probably
will be
although the thing about it I'll wake up
as usual at 7am he won't wake up until
noon
then he'll come in and be like don't
talk about me while I'm not around
why you do
intense
intense what is it called wait wait what
does it say electric citrus
intense yeah taurine ginseng Karana
that's the Dollar General
it's probably it's got the same [ __ ] in
it it's like [ __ ] I drank it before
yeah it's probably got the same [ __ ] it
is I just like the taste Red Bull or I
know they all taste the same to me like
I said they all taste like
Sweet Tarts rubbed against someone's ass
tried it no
Tarts rubbed against somebody's ass
pretty much that's how Jenny describes
everything
so that's how I describe energy drinks
because that's what they all taste full
of [ __ ] that's what they all taste like
to me
it tastes like if you took the worst
flavor of Sweet Tart did you not taste
it and rubbed it on your tape and then
ate it
that's what it they that's what they
like they do taste like Sweet Tarts they
don't taste anything like ass as far as
I know you're the only one with nowhere
to ass tastes like I don't know what it
has oh you wouldn't know that see no I
would not know I would not know
like ass
no
I'm just using ass as a general term as
like just something that doesn't really
taste it no
why do you keep trying it's like sweet
why do you persist it's like Sweet Tarts
I don't like Sweet Tarts either
and I especially don't like Sweet Tarts
with whatever the [ __ ] it is that they
put in energy drinks that makes it taste
like ass
[Laughter]
but every single time he always tries to
get me to drink it he always tries to
get me to drink it does not tastes like
it is I have never tasted a single one
that tasted good
sometimes it's kind of like the Sweet
Tarts that you get from [ __ ] on
Halloween
that doesn't make it better they're all
bad
the only energy drinks that I've had
that were
drinkable were the ones that were like
coffee flavored like the rock star
coffee ones those ones were okay they're
not great I would rather just have like
a regular coffee drink without all the
[ __ ] that they put in there because
it tastes weird to me but those were the
only ones that I could actually like
drink without being like it tastes fine
it tastes fine to you it tastes fine
to me it doesn't
yeah Danny Rowling said the monster
coffee Loca mochas are my favorite see
those are good like those are okay I
wouldn't choose it but if I had to like
really kind of power up on caffeine and
energy and stuff yeah I drink one of
those those are all right but honestly
like I would rather just have a coffee
drink without all the extra
[ __ ] in it
Zach says iced or regular coffee they're
both good they're both good and honestly
like depending on
I don't know I I like regular coffee
most of the time but I like iced coffee
most of the time too like
depends on what the weather is I guess
granther said if I got that drunk I'd be
nursing a hangover until Monday
Zach says I know what an ass tastes like
of course you do so I kind of feel like
most people do probably but they just
want to admit it
um Daniel Rowling says 300 shot Monster
Energy mocha and french vanilla are
pretty decent
yeah like I said I've had the Locum you
know whatever what is it called Loca
mocha that's pretty good stop looking at
it
she's over sitting over there looking at
the [ __ ] saying
you're so weird Pokey you're crazy leave
it alone
she gets very upset when the like the
the ceiling fan is on very upset
she keeps trying to like tell us that
the ceiling fan is on it's like we know
the ceiling fan is on yeah but she's
like you guys you guys she keeps trying
she's like sitting over there on the
thing I see you I know
and then she's like she's very seriously
looking
yeah I don't understand to both of us
like what can you like do something
about this or what yeah
um
granther says my bunion is telling me
this
this show is heading in a dark and
belligerent Direction Zach says your
bunion communicates with you damn this
is crazy
where is this bunion located it's on his
foot somewhere
that wasn't what I thought but okay okay
I don't know if it's like so much dark
and belligerent I'm just kind of like
mystified as to
look at this look at this
I mean
not to leave soon she's picking on me
I'm not picking on you I'm just saying
it's like look at this look at this I
can't help it you can't help it no you
could have you could have helped it
earlier I'm fighting it but look what
happened
[Laughter]
all right I just thought well I kind of
feel like I thought you want some of
this no okay I don't I told you how many
times do I have to tell you I don't like
those I don't like those I don't I don't
know why
do you mean shut up like you you keep
offering that no you said you're getting
jealous of the [ __ ] you're getting
jealous of the [ __ ]
energy drink
what okay
now you're just starting to like go off
into like [ __ ] delusional la la lands
at this point getting jealous over the
drink okay I'm jealous of your can of
Dollar General energy drinks it was only
a dollar too
that [ __ ] was a dog I am so jealous that
it was only a dollar what's up
okay I don't know what you're talking
about
yeah obviously Tom needs a hug from baby
Yoda no I'm not weird kitties
I'm not really sure what I'm not worried
about anything I'm not really sure what
yeah
I mean all right then all right then
yeah what time is it
it's like 7 30 7 30 it's 10 early
7 30. what's up come on oh my God
uh Zach says can you do drunk elrond
no
oh man you're no fun no
no you can't even do El Rod come on
stick your lips out why do the fish lips
come on
you have to understand so there you go
see I knew you could do it I know you
could I believe in Utah I believe in you
Tom
we're dealing with Earth and Earth and
the Earth the Earth was sphere
and in the orthosphere earthosphere yeah
that's the ship
elrad would come up with yeah it does
sound like in the orthosphere
underneath
the [ __ ] uh the Rays and underneath
the Rays of [ __ ] electricity okay
okay uh okay inside the sphere of
[ __ ] um
what do you call this [ __ ] radiation
okay we have to understand that nuclear
nuclear energy is only possible okay on
the Earth's [ __ ] planosphere
and on the Earth's planosphere when we
have nuclear energy we can move ships of
different sizes and aircraft different
sizes and uh
and if if you are totally in tune and
the plan is clear you'll get free energy
okay
and uh yeah and sign me up
[Laughter]
sign me up to your cult yeah and then uh
take all my money
once the plan is clear
then what
then what
wow you have to understand what's the
plan there you go there you go
then we can all we can all hang out
and travel to distant universes and
different Stars
and once we're there we can have our own
aircraft they look just like DC nines
and we'll fly around
and we'll all film our own movies
they'll all be based upon Greece
with the movie Grease oh okay I thought
he was a country
okay okay I'm done with that I really I
really like Greece so we're we're gonna
do like a whole extended Universe of
like Grease the movie
one of our greatest scientologists of
course and he made the movie Grease
and it was a musical about high school
and high schools everywhere throughout
the entire Galactic Continuum and in
some and in some universes like all the
high school students are 40 years old so
there's that too high school students
are always 40 years old because because
they have sex
and when they have sex they are on me
they become 40 years yeah they
immediately become 40 years old
um
um excuse me like um L Ron can I make a
spin-off movie about cha-cha
about what about Cha-Cha you talk about
the the dancer Cha-Cha yeah yeah well
can I make a spin-off movie about her
she's been off series actually I would
like to make a spin-off series about
Cha-Cha you gotta understand something
may I do that Cha-Cha is that allowed
Cha-Cha existed not another plan
the same skirt and everything
um she was based upon an andorian and
drillian
female
did she come out of a volcano sir she
came out of a vagina
well everyone came out of a vagina
that's not exciting yeah
[Laughter]
a volcanic vagina oh God was there all
right I was there I saw it wow I saw it
I licked it
it was lava involved it was the whole
thing what was the whole thing right all
right
[Laughter]
this went to a weird place didn't it
no it's not weird at all
you need to understand the uh the human
container room uh and then uh here then
we'll drink this and the next we'll be
on the free wins sailing on the waves
on our way to Florida
okay
it's access isn't a volcanic cabins I
mean volcanic vagina maybe just having
your period
um
yeah
yeah pretty much yeah that's that's what
that's like case you haven't experienced
it
Sebastian Moran said I want 10 pints of
what Tom's been drinking well what were
you drinking before I got there and no
it's just tequila oh too cute he was
drinking tequila before I got there and
then when I got there I got uh just a
screwdriver and then he started getting
screwdrivers and I think he had one or
two more like after I was there yeah I
don't know how much I drank a lot
obviously yeah a lot tequila and vodka
you mixed your Liquors yeah
that's a myth though no it's all the
same
that's what I'm saying I think a lot of
people have a thing where it's like oh
don't mix the licorice together or don't
isn't there like that thing it's like um
what's that [ __ ] saying that
everybody says you can't jump beer
against liquor well what
beer after liquor never sicker or
something like I can't remember what it
is but they're they're just like don't
mix like beer and liquor but I've
honestly it's all alcohol and I really
don't the dumbest one is that you're not
supposed to be [ __ ] swimming after
you drink
that's [ __ ] ridiculous well they just
don't want you to drown yeah it's
ridiculous because I could see I've been
drunk enough that if I went swimming
after I probably have drowned yeah
so I can see that but
um so maybe that's what they're talking
about I don't know what
I think that's what they're talking
about because I that I'm sure that's
probably happened I could see that
happening I could see that happening
I've because like I said I've been drunk
enough for totally like I said hey I'm
gonna go swimming [ __ ] Lake Eola or
something like that and then I went
swimming and then I drowned I could see
that I could see that
so maybe that's what they're getting at
I never really heard that so much though
I heard that more as like
well wasn't it always kind of like don't
swim after you eat
like for an hour because you're gonna
get cramps or something I don't know
I don't know
Dave says dealing with my youngest son's
first breakup
uh satin washed High Fidelity together
oh High Fidelity is such a good movie
other suggestions for great breakup
movies oh [ __ ]
High Fidelity is great but um
man I'm trying to think like some better
break up movies breakup movies
I can probably think of like some good
ones maybe if I wasn't so
I wasn't in a braided also I mean High
Fidelity is going man I need to like
re-watch that
I saw that in the theater I think you've
probably never seen it right never heard
of it
okay
it's good it's good John Cusack is in it
based on it's based on Nick Hornby novel
is it not
yeah
I mean I remember that being really good
it was like a guy that like worked at a
record store
it's good it's really good
uh Daniel Rowling said hopefully some
good movies come out to see on
Thanksgiving Day is anybody excited
about I don't know much about it
admittedly but isn't there a new Knives
Out movie coming out I said with Daniel
Craig yeah there is
because we I really liked Knives Out
that's all right and so he's gonna like
play another like he's gonna do another
thing like as that same character it's
called Glass Onion like the Beatles song
yeah
so
I don't know
it might be good
I want to see it Rebecca says only
breakup movies I know result in Murder
yeah that's kind of like that's what I
was thinking of too I was for a second
like my brain went there I'm like
breakup movies and I'm like oh wait no
somebody got killed at the end of that
one that's probably not what he's
talking about
uh wasn't say anything a breakup movie
also with John Cusack that was the first
thing that jumped to my mind
um
was that technically a breakup movie
though because they did kind of get well
I they kind of got together in the end
though right
but I mean say anything was still good
though
I'll watch John Cusack in anything he's
[ __ ] awesome I love John Cusack let's
jump
yeah good
you all right yeah she's over here
looking at me what you doing poop
she's looking at you like all these kids
like what's the matter with Daddy yeah
she's like what is he gonna be able to
give me a meat sticks later because I
don't really worry about herself
come on Boop well yeah that's her thing
yes because
we have like there's like a routine
where you know it's like seven eight
o'clock at night everybody's like kind
of gets ready for bed or whatever and
then we get in bed to like watch movies
and then Pookie comes running into the
room and she's like
can I have a meat stick please and
she'll like sit by the bed and like make
her cute little face because we keep the
meat sticks like in you know the thing
by the um by the bed like the nightstand
so she knows that's where they are so
she comes in she makes like that she
makes like big eyes like
meatstick time so she's used to like you
know Daddy taking the meat stick out of
the thing and like holding it because
she'll sit there and like lick it and
then bite it [ __ ] it's like a whole
routine
so she gets used to that so if anything
interferes with that routine she's like
she gets very very like antsy about it
she's like is Daddy not gonna be able to
give me the bait stick or he's not gonna
be able to like hold it or what's going
on like she gets like really upset about
it he's like really really funny
granther says great breakup movie
Boyhood with Ethan Hawke oh yeah that's
a good one his son's girlfriend leaves
him for a lacrosse player Ethan tells
him don't worry there are plenty of
classy of us
that was actually a good movie uh just
fatal attractions
uh it does it does I guess by what
definition I'm not entirely sure but you
know
um and Sebastian morenza's identity is a
good film it is
um I kind of feel like did we review
that one
please tell me we did
maybe I reviewed it
I saw that in the theater when it came
out like I said I will watch anything
that John Cusack is in because I love
him
I think I saw identity in the theater
but I thought that we had reviewed
identity not too long ago
because I thought we just rewatched it
like while we were in this house and
we've only been in this house for like a
year
Dave says identity rocks big fan of John
Cusack when I was in college back in the
90s Gross Point Blank is in my top 10
gifts but man gross point blank was so
good and that's another one that I have
to like [ __ ] re-watch I think I saw
that in the theater too
now that you mention it
and let's see do do
don't mix grain and grape I think I've
never heard that one I usually heard
and I can't remember what the order is
it's always kind of like
beer and liquor never sicker
liquor and beer I don't remember whether
there's like a rhyme that goes along
with it but like I said I think it's
mostly like an urban legend because
honestly like alcohol is alcohol and you
know whatever you drink it's gonna like
[ __ ] you up the next day although I have
exp like in my in my personal experience
I have
um had a thing where
different types of alcohol do affect me
in slightly different ways not always
but sometimes like um
if I go out somewhere where they don't
have hard liquor and so I usually just
drink beer if I just drink a bunch of
beer and I get drunk on that like I
won't get belligerent or I won't get
like I'll get drunk but usually I'll
just get like super super sleepy like
honestly
um and maybe that's all the carbs like
I'll just have like some beers and I'm
just like man mostly I just have to pee
a lot and I'm just like really really
tired whereas if I go out and drink you
know a [ __ ] ton of vodka or a [ __ ] ton
of you know other hard liquor
then usually I'll get like super super
ooh like party mode or I'll get really
really angry
um that both of those things whiskey
tends to make me angrier than vodka but
not always and gin as much as I love gin
if I will usually like throw up if I
drink gin but I think that's just
because of the like acidity more than
the alcohol I think that's just because
you know you drink it and it has kind of
like lime and all that kind of other
kind of stuff in it and like there's so
much it's so acidic that usually it just
makes me want to barf so that's what
that happens so if I drink well like
more than one gin and tonic I'll usually
throw up
uh Zach says no time to die is
technically a breakup movie too okay
uh I guess it is I guess it is
uh Blue Moon is my favorite beer so Zach
uh yeah Sebastian said you did Jenny
matinee lab I thought we had I thought
we had I was pretty sure that we had
covered that movie at some point
we did identity right
the one with John Cusack and like all
they were all his personality spoiler
alert they were all his uh other
personalities
I don't remember
well
yeah right yeah all right can I run to
the bathroom now or are you gonna be
able to like good are you gonna go good
good are you gonna be able to talk okay
good okay I'll talk to the whole thing
we'll see yeah I can hear you see she
doesn't believe me
she's a baby
she's trying to tell the cat not to
watch her why she pees
she couldn't shut the door shut the door
shut the door
there's a door on that bathroom anyway
Pokey do not watch your mama take a pee
don't do it
see she doesn't think I can actually
talk through
the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] break okay I'm gonna talk
I'm gonna see what everybody's saying
I'm gonna put my [ __ ] on
everything's fine
I'm just up at the bar
do my thing and then she shows up and we
started drinking
it's on a [ __ ] Friday of all things
how it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
let's see what everybody's saying
okay
all right
okay
let's see
Zach says that no time to die is a
breakup flake
uh yeah it kind of was a breakup flick
but they had to break up because [ __ ]
Bond got killed that was a good flick
though I I like no time today
yeah Zach's mad about that movie
Rebecca's saying there was an Alaskan
serial killer in frozen ground
me
all right I don't know if he's talking
about
okay now
Dave says that frozen ground was great
uh true uh Chrome flick
which is a coup set well she's back
she's back
okay well you like laughing like
seriously what's that
who nobody was laughing now uh before
like what Pookie does yeah is in the
middle of the night because like a lot
of times because I'm old so I have to
get up in the middle and I just like pee
in the middle of night so this bathroom
that I have right here has two doors one
to the hall and one to this office
so usually I'll close the hall door but
I'll leave the office One open so
sometimes Pookie will run in like while
I'm going to the bathroom and like stare
at me which is like really really weird
so I tell her it's like hey I'm using
the litter box do you mind and like you
know what I mean and it's just like I
don't know why she wants to come in and
like watch what she's interested
other people too because of how you do
it she does it well that's what I mean
there's like all of these videos that go
around YouTube where people it's a whole
sub-genre of people that take pictures
of their cats like they're sitting on
the toilet like with their pants around
their ankles and like the cat is like
sitting in their pants like looking up
at them like while they're going to the
bath that's like a whole sub-genre she
never does that but she does like
sometimes run it if you leave the door
open and be like hey what you doing and
I'm like okay she wants to know how you
do it I'm going to the bathroom poke
yeah yeah everybody goes to the bathroom
huh you want to go to the bathroom she
goes look at her you wanna know how you
do it oh my god look she's all like
intense she's like don't touch me she's
trying to run away he's trying to run
away
Daddy's [ __ ] up she knows yeah she
knows go ahead
now she's looking back at me what's up
with you yeah
she knows something's matter with you
don't don't do that
she's like why why are you she's looking
at him her little tail is like oh what
what
yeah she doesn't she doesn't know what
to make of you Tom
now she's [ __ ] laying down looking at
me
he'll be all right
it's all good just give him some time
yeah it's all good he'll recover yeah
she's like I'm not really sure what to
do about this
like you you were [ __ ] up yeah she
knows like I said
okay she knows when people are [ __ ] up
and she knows when people are mad or if
they're in a bad mood or something like
that it's just like she's very very good
at like reading people's emotions
Charlie says hi from Argentina love this
show oh that's good thank you very much
Charlie holy crap all the way down in
Argentina that's like on the other side
of the planet well yeah it's the other
side of that side of the planet like not
the other side of that yeah vertically
not horizontally I miss South America
though yeah
yeah where are you and see where are you
in Argentina
you must be uh
Buenos Aires Maybe
maybe even more south
down by
[ __ ] Antarctica
we'll see
yeah I mean I'm glad people are enjoying
it because yeah I'm not really sure like
what to make of this whole situation
I've seen you like really drunk before
but I've never seen you this drunk on
the show some people don't like Daniel
Craig films I'm not worried about all
that I want to actually want to see I
know they don't but it's like okay Glass
Onion again because I well no
um we haven't seen Glass Onion yet I
want to see it but Knives Out I saw
knives yeah we saw knives out of this it
was good I really like I like knives
well I like Murder Mysteries and I liked
that it was like an old school murder
mystery because they don't make a lot of
things anymore and I kind of liked that
it kind of like reminded me of like old
[ __ ] from like the 70s and I was like
kind of into that you know Ryan
Johnson's [ __ ] Star Wars [ __ ]
sucked but [ __ ] Knives Out I liked it
well I kind of feel like that's more
like the [ __ ] that he likes to do right
like I said old school like Agatha
Christie type horror like I said I'm
into that like I like those old kind of
like mystery kind of well if it's
playing we'll we got AMC we'll run down
and see it yeah well I told you there's
a million [ __ ] movies I don't even
know if a lot of them are playing
anymore but there's a lot of ones that
oh
um I still want to see nope uh is this
still planned no but I think peacock is
gonna stream it okay like but I don't
know when because I saw a commercial and
they were like oh that's coming soon so
maybe it'll be like streaming on there
because I really still do want to well
uh okay tomorrow
when you wake up
select us a [ __ ] time to go and see
the new uh
like I said if it's playing I'm not just
playing but I'll look and like I said
there was a ton of horror movies I still
wanted to say we never got to see black
phone uh I still wanted to see smile I
don't know if that's still playing or
not
um you know most of them are probably
coming streaming now so I'll probably
just watch them I hung up but you know
what I mean Zach says you know something
I've been thinking is not only is
hereditary one of the scariest movies
I've seen but one of the saddest two
Tony Collette screaming after the girl
dies is so heartbreaking honestly I kind
of wish I'm still kind of mad that like
Tony Collette didn't even get like a um
like an Oscar none for anything you know
she didn't get a [ __ ] nomination for
that [ __ ] which
I know that like the Oscars are not real
big on horror movies
um but you know it's gotten better over
the years but come on God damn it I mean
that was clearly
clearly like a case where they should
have like
really
you know
singled that out
just saying yeah
Dave says uh hereditary was not just a
great horror but a very well made film
Tony Collette is excellent all the
acting in that was excellent I mean
that's one of those movies that I just
kind of see myself returning to again
and again which
in the best kind of way that's like a
movie that the first time I saw it I was
like yeah I never want to [ __ ] watch
that ever again because it was like
[ __ ] horrifying and it made me feel
terrible but it's like then I I just
kept thinking about it and then I
watched it a second time and then I was
like man I need to like keep watching
this because there's like so much detail
in it that you missed like the first few
times around that it's like every single
time you watch it just like The Shining
it's like every single time you watch it
there's like new [ __ ] that keeps like
coming out that's Kubrick though it's
amazingly I mean but the thing about
hereditary is that it's amazingly made
like so much thought went into it that
the every single time you watch it
subsequently you pick up more details
like more stuff that's going on in the
background like all the stuff that was
added it was just kind of like
so much thought went into it and I just
think that was like so awesome because
you don't really see like a lot of that
stuff nowadays
um
Tammy says um talking about cats
watching you uh while you're while
you're going to bathroom they do it to
make you sure you are protected because
that's when they are at their most
vulnerable while going potty yeah I kind
of feel like that's kind of how I try to
take it even though I always tell her
it's like don't be weird Mommy's going
pee but like that's kind of like I guess
that's why they're just kind of like oh
mommy's using the litter box so it's
like I better watch and make sure I
don't like nothing bad happens but I
don't know it's still like pretty weird
um Dave says just to clarify I love
Daniel Craig I just wasn't clean uh keen
on the Bond films no the Bond films were
good just go back and see him
I mean but not everybody's gonna like
not everyone is alive
you know yeah you know I liked them all
but Daniel Craig I kind of feel like um
you would probably like some like some
of the movies that he was in prior to
him being in the Bond films like I still
kind of want you to see layer cake yeah
because I kind of feel like you would
probably like that I thought I thought
he was greatest Bond
he was a great Bond I really liked him
as Bond but I liked him as an actor
before I even saw him in the Bond movie
as he was in like a lot of British crime
movies like I said if you saw layer cake
you'd probably like that
Rebecca says I saw a nope just last
weekend uh in my opinion it was [ __ ]
yeah I don't know like it looked cool
like from the thing but I still want to
see it though because I liked his other
movies I really liked get out and I
really liked us so
I don't know we'll see I still like want
to see it but honestly like there's a
lot of other movies that I want to see
that have come out I'm not really all
that Keen on
um
you know like Halloween ends it's like I
kind of want to see it but I'm not
really that jazzed about it most people
say it sucked I mean yeah so it's just
kind of like
yeah I'll see it when I see it I'm not
really that worried about it I would
rather see ones that were like not
part of like a franchise so like I said
I was more keen to see like black phone
or smile or things like that I was
really excited to see like Barbarian
which was you know played in the
theaters and then I got to see it on
whatever streaming and that was awesome
I kind of wish I had seen that in the
theater actually you know when it was
playing but Louie said something about
Star Wars and uh Craig or not Craig uh
Brian Brian Jonathan Ryan Johnson read
that off what he said Ryan Johnson
single-handedly ruined Star Wars in my
opinion I don't think it was
single-handedly
I'm gonna put that on Disney
Disney did not have
an overarching story
if you're gonna make a trilogy
you can't have three different directors
making up their own yeah you kind of
need to plan that out you have to have a
plan all right so I put that I put that
on [ __ ] Kathleen Kennedy and her
[ __ ] team that they didn't have a
story okay they let
they let directors write their own
[ __ ] [ __ ] and that's just not how you
do a [ __ ] Trilogy it'll never work
out three different directors you have
to have a story and
Disney didn't have one and that was the
problem
yeah yeah I don't know if it was one
person's fault but yeah like you said if
you're if you're planning on doing a
Trilogy you have to have a story plan
that [ __ ] out before you even start
filming anything right because you have
to have a consistent Vision you have to
have a consistent like [ __ ] end game
everybody has to be on the same page
right you know what I mean at least in
my opinion like you know what they did
was they took [ __ ] um oh what's his
name who's [ __ ] up a lot of Star Trek
movies uh what was his name Abrams
Abrams JJ Abrams who is the guy who can
write a good story but he can't write a
good ending
um it took him
and they gave him the first installment
and then they gave it to Ryan Johnson
and there's no [ __ ] story arc for
this Trilogy he said just make it work
that's not how it goes man it doesn't
work that way
um
I would think that [ __ ]
I think that [ __ ] Ryan Johnson
actually did a good job if you put
if you put it in the context of that he
didn't he wasn't given a story to tell
they told him to write the story
well yeah just do what you want right
which like I said he just did what he
wanted he did what he wanted to do
that's what I mean that's what I don't
like I'm not mad about it no I'm not mad
about it but I'm just saying that it's
like it probably would have been better
if you'd have if you'd given it to one
writer director or you know two people a
writer and a director and said you guys
write a story that's like three
installments and we're gonna make that
into three movies so it has to go this
way
all cohesive and like [ __ ] like that
approach it like you're making a single
movie except it's like really really
long that's how I would right like so
I'm not gonna put it on Ryan Johnson
I've studied it from every angle he's a
good director all right it's just that
they put it all on his shoulders
to [ __ ]
Kathleen it falls on Kathleen Kennedy
okay she didn't ha and she didn't write
any of that [ __ ] it's just that she she
was in charge of that department there
should have been a story outline for all
the directors that were gonna be on the
project like this is how the story goes
here's your story arc make that [ __ ]
this is how it's gonna go make it work
uh it would have been a lot better they
just told him to write it as they go and
that'll net that won't work that won't
work well that kind of works out the way
a lot of the sequels worked out like in
the 80s before they even knew like oh
we're gonna make a movie and we didn't
even know if it was going to be
successful but then it was successful so
everybody said oh make a sequel and then
we're like well [ __ ] now what do we do
and then they had to like [ __ ] back
right some [ __ ] that like fit into the
older [ __ ] so I kind of feel like
nowadays now that everybody yeah now
that everybody knows that it's like
we're going into this knowing that you
know it's going to be a series or it's
going to be a Trilogy you really need to
like plan for that going into it so you
have a vision from the get-go so
everything is cohesive right I'm a big
fan of like theming from the beginning
and that's something that really has to
come with like planning yeah because JJ
Abrams installed his installment wasn't
bad they were building on something that
was good
and then and then and then [ __ ] um uh
Brian Johnson comes in Ryan Johnson yeah
Ryan Johnson comes in and his story
wasn't bad either it's just that
no it's starting to fall apart now okay
and some of the [ __ ] that was in there
some of the scenes just were not in the
same tone the uh the [ __ ] flying
Princess Leia through space no that
wasn't the right that wasn't that wasn't
Star Wars tone
um the casino scene
that was Star Wars but that was bad Star
Wars all right uh that was like
something out of the prequels worse
um
and then the third movie
the third movie
most of the third movie involved fixing
the second movie
which really kind of [ __ ] it up but
that movie could have been really good
there was some good [ __ ] in that
but there was also some really bad [ __ ]
riding the horses along the [ __ ] edge
of the dam
Star Destroyer unlimited Star Destroyers
coming up out of the [ __ ] ground that
was kind of like something out of the
dam
video games like the [ __ ] Knights of
the Old Republic with star Forge
there was some Star Wars
Heritage to that it's just that that
story was not worked up into that where
you could do that and and get the
[ __ ] plausible deniability that you
needed they were rushing those stories
and it's because of the damn confusion
there wasn't a story arc written for the
trilogy that was the problem
yeah and honestly like I said I'm not
gonna blame like one particular person I
kind of feel like that's something that
I mean that's Star Wars that's a big
deal it's a big deal you should have all
sat together with whatever writers and
directors were going to be working on
this stuff and be like what are we
thinking like this is the story that
we're gonna come out come up with and
it's gonna like stretch over three
movies
and this is what's gonna happen in this
movie this is what's gonna have just a
broad outline like you could give people
you know a leeway in their own thing but
it's just kind of like we want to
establish the beginning like what's the
tone gonna be like what's the what's the
whole thematic thrust of the thing gonna
be like over the three movies like I
just kind of feel like they didn't
really do that and that's kind of like a
shame because I mean especially in this
day and age when everybody is so focused
on
um you know the bigger picture and it's
like you know we're you know doing a
whole series or we're doing a Trilogy or
whatever like everything is focused on
on that more than like a one you know
just a one-off story so I kind of feel
like you really need to get your all
your [ __ ] together before you even start
making anything yeah because if you
don't
you're inevitably gonna end up
in the middle of [ __ ] and you're gonna
be like wait where are we going now and
it's just kind of like you're gonna end
up at sixes and sevens because you
didn't plan anything ahead of time
especially in a world where you have a
bunch of [ __ ] Star Wars fans online
well that too and that's like I said
that adds like you know a million times
like more right uh you know now there's
good Star Wars out there Mandalorian
season one and two I thought were
[ __ ] awesome I thought they were
[ __ ] great
now the Disney Corporation and the
people in charge of the Disney
corporations are [ __ ] ups all right uh
they never should have gotten there
dipped their feet into politics and what
the public thinks [ __ ] the public and
[ __ ] politics that's not what Star Wars
was Star Wars is not supposed to be
divisive it's just supposed to be a
story it's a [ __ ] Western it's a
samurai Western that's all it is okay
it's not supposed to be there to teach
people anything you know that's not what
it was so um what was his name [ __ ]
um
felony no what was the guy that did the
[ __ ] um the uh the the two Star Wars
seasons I thought they were great for
Mandalorian
John Favreau Favreau yeah I think that
guy really should be in charge of Star
Wars because he is in some of the Marvel
movies too yeah and the reason why I
think he should be in charge of Star
Wars is because he understands the tone
he loves Star Wars he loves Star Wars
and he knows the two Super Fan okay yeah
he's got he's also a Marvel Super Fan
yeah
because Star Wars is tone he's in a lot
of the Spider-Man movies yeah he didn't
know you got [ __ ] that think
it's visuals that Star Wars is about
what it visually looks like no
it's emotional tone
and first and second season of
Mandalorian the tone was correct
that's what that's Star Wars
it's a samurai flick man it's [ __ ]
Kurosawa all right that's what it is
well like I said and a lot of people
pointed out that the Mandalorian uh the
reason why it worked was because it was
essentially based on Lone Wolf and Cobb
yeah yeah Lone Wolf and cup it's a
[ __ ] it's a Samurai movie sure it's
Japanese with a western Flair
and he understands that
a lot of corporate [ __ ] suits don't
really get it
all right they don't know what made Star
Wars strong what made it great
it's just like what they're doing with
[ __ ]
it's just like what they did with
[ __ ] Indiana Jones okay
Spielberg knew what made [ __ ] Indiana
Jones strong all right that was a
Spielberg thing it was a it was a retro
[ __ ] series is what it was
you have to look at this from the from
the from the Viewpoint of the 1930s
yeah it was like an old cereal yeah that
was kind of like the tone they wanted
from the beginning and it worked in that
context you can't modernize
Indiana Jones
what people like people like right that
it was like a throwback right yeah they
like that tone of it it was retro back
in the 70s you can't [ __ ] modernize
that it was [ __ ] old school and
traditional
and that's what made it great
because there were certain things back
in the 30s that they got right
the 30s was nothing to laugh at we're
watching 30s horror movies we just
watched Dracula's daughter last night
which we will be reviewing on Tuesday
yeah
they knew what they were doing back in
the 30s it wasn't modern but they
understood the way people were
they were very strong stories
because they were they were simple they
were Primal all right
um
and that's and people like that kind of
[ __ ] although I will say that a lot of
the stuff that flew in the 30s and 40s I
don't think it would fly nowadays
because it wasn't as sophisticated right
like because you have to do you have to
like make adjustments for nowadays
people are a lot more whether you like
it or not people are a lot more um
sophisticated in regards to storytelling
And in regards to like all different
kind of things like having to do with
movie making and stuff like that so you
can't really get away with a lot of
stuff that you would have got away with
back in the 1930s because back then yes
it was very simplistic and a lot of that
still works nowadays but I don't know if
you could make a movie like if you made
a movie that was exactly like one from
the 1930s like the same pacing and the
same kind of acting and everything like
that that would not fly it would not
play no because too much time has passed
yeah people are a lot more I'm not
saying people back then were
unsophisticated but I'm just saying that
like
people nowadays are a lot more media
Savvy you know what I mean so it's like
they've seen all of the movies you know
subsequently since the 1930s so it's
like we're a lot more aware of like
storytelling tricks and like [ __ ] you
know anything to do with media so people
are a lot more sophisticated in that
regard so you can't really like get away
with the same kind of stuff that you do
if you look at if you look at Indiana
Jones though it was 30s but it was
updated that's what I mean and I think
that that was well and that's what I
mean I think that's why the Indiana
Jones movies worked is because they took
all the best [ __ ] from like the 1930s
serials but they updated them only as
far as they needed to right
um for a modern audience you know they
retained all the stuff that worked back
in the 30s but then updated like a
couple of things you know just to kind
of um you know work with people that
were you know grew up in the 80s or
whatever and it's so it kind of like was
a perfect balance of that so but that's
a really hard balance to strike and I
kind of feel like a lot of people can't
do that like Spielberg was kind of like
you know obviously he's a legend for a
reason because he was one of the dudes
that could do that he knew what would
work from the old school [ __ ] and what
you needed to update but could put it
together in a way that was pleasing to
both things and it wasn't just which is
hard to do it's like harder to do than
it sounds like and it wasn't just 30
genre he could do that modern too it's
like with jaws
and with uh [ __ ] um uh Close
Encounters I mean Spielberg was [ __ ]
he was a master
at how to make a story appeal to an
audience and really he can make a story
appeal to an audience across time
you know now could he come out and do
that right now maybe maybe not directors
have a half-life you know what I mean
but I mean Spielberg Spielberg was good
more than anybody I mean he had a very
very long run I mean look at the [ __ ]
look at the [ __ ] that he did over the
years I mean that's amazing if you had a
20 three-year-old Spielberg appear right
now with new material and news in a new
movie he can make a Blockbuster
they had to be young there was something
that had to be young and energetic and
be very positive that was part of what a
director was you know
uh once they got kind of jaded and old
and [ __ ] worn out their movies
weren't quite as good
there was uh some about them you can you
can just watch the movies they have a
half-life
well I kind of feel like that happens to
anybody like anybody that has any kind
of like artistic band or any anybody
that is into like an art form that
trades on being
Progressive or Cutting Edge or anything
like that obviously younger
you know people younger directors
younger artists stuff like that that's
going to be like the Vanguard yeah once
people get older and more comfortable
it's like they don't need to like you
know somebody like Steven Spielberg
maybe like after he made like his
millions he's like I don't really need
to innovate anymore I don't really need
to like go outside of the box anymore
like once that kind of happens you kind
of like lose the impetus not always
because some people kind of still stay
Innovative like you know like I said I
bring up a lot like people like David
Lynch or you know somebody like that
who's still [ __ ] weird even though
he's like old
um but he's always been outside of the
mainstream but I kind of feel like
somebody like Spielberg his best [ __ ]
was when he was still like kind of Young
and Hungry yeah and needed to prove
himself to somebody like once he's
already like proved himself and
established himself you kind of like
even if not consciously you kind of like
feel like oh well I'm you know I've
established myself I have money I'm
comfortable now and it's like I don't
need to push the boundaries I don't need
to like do anything new anymore so they
kind of like rest on their Laurels a
little bit which you know it's it
happens that's just what happens that's
just kind of like a natural well they're
fat and comfortable they're not that's
what I mean they don't really have to
like I said people that don't
whether they're young or poor or
whatever that gives them like more
impetus to innovate or like do something
different because they're like trying
different things because they don't have
anything to lose once you are we'll see
you Becca
see you back I know like yeah she's in
Australia yeah her phone's dying oh yeah
sorry I'm glad you came by to join us
though
but yeah so that's the thing I kind of
feel like
especially like I said somebody likes
Spielberg who
you know had so much success early
and you know and he had like so you know
he had he did [ __ ] Jaws for Christ's
sake yeah and then he had like all those
movies like in the 80s and he was just
like this big thing but after that it's
like it's just kind of like well I can
retire now because I already have all
this like behind me so Sebastian he said
duel wasn't a bad film no duel was a
great film yeah well and then if it made
for TV type film and and uh yeah now he
was good it's real good well yeah that
was Steven Spielberg one of his earliest
tv films and based on a short story by
Richard Matheson who is actually one of
my favorite authors I have a um I have a
book somewhere it's somewhere I think
it's on that shelf over there that is
dual and like a lot of other Richard
Mathis in short stories but
um in case you guys didn't know like
Steven Spielberg did a lot of TV movies
like early on in his career duel his
best known but he also did one called
something evil
which was kind of like a
haunted house slash pagan-ish kind of
thing and that is also worth watching
it's not as good as dual I'm not gonna
say that but something evil is actually
like really good too so if you haven't
seen that like check that out also like
I think I wrote about it like a long
time ago but I feel like a lot of people
haven't seen that one a lot of people
talk about dual but not so much that one
um do you want to get something to eat
uh yeah probably okay I'm gonna make us
something to eat okay when you get a
chance I'm gonna shut it down somebody
you want to shut it down it is we've
been going for a couple of hours you
said that I'll make us something to eat
I got uh I got pumpkin soup
um I got sandwiches I got tacos I got
everything you want I mean pumpkin soup
and a sandwich would be good okay all
right because I got ham slices too Zach
says uh Scorsese just turned 80
yesterday and he's still releasing
bangers I don't think he's made a truly
bad movie either yeah I mean his [ __ ]
was good well that's what I mean it's
like I'm you know I don't really mean to
say that across the board because like I
said you know David Lynch is my favorite
director and he's like old as [ __ ] and
he still makes like he's still weird as
[ __ ] and I'm there for it I'm I'm really
like loving but he's always kind of been
like a little bit on the fringes I kind
of feel like Spielberg is a different
case because he was so mainstream at
some time and like his his stamp is like
so much over the 80s I kind of feel like
in a big way that you know if anybody's
a mainstream like Blockbuster director
or Spielberg is
but you know maybe it'd be better
example to talk about something like
John Carpenter or somebody like that
who's always kind of been like a little
bit on the outside but like with
sometimes sort of mainstream and stuff
like that but you know you're never
really recovered from his loss of of the
thing well yeah you really should have
been a great it was a great movie and it
should it was not recognized because
that's what I mean it made me so sad
that it's like it that that wasn't
recognized as a masterpiece which it is
until much later and I think that [ __ ]
with them a little bit which like I get
it I get it you would have [ __ ] up my
mind
that's what I'm saying it's like I
understand like I If I had made a move
if I had made the thing yeah back in the
early 80s and then and like everybody
had like [ __ ] on it yeah and then like
oh later they'd been like oh it's a
masterpiece I've been like man [ __ ] all
y'all yeah I'd have been mad too I get
it as a kid my dad went to go see the
thing we saw it [ __ ] twice at least
and we were blown away [ __ ] ET E.T was
out no [ __ ] at we were seeing the thing
it was [ __ ] us up and like I said
today you can watch the thing today and
that is still a [ __ ] amazing movie
yeah that totally holds up yeah totally
great and a lot of movies don't from
that era but that movie is absolutely
but it just makes me sad that it took so
long for people to recognize how [ __ ]
awesome it was but I can understand like
how Carpenter was like pissed off by
that because I know I don't know John
Carpenter personally but like I've seen
like enough interviews with him it's
like he's a very very
um I don't want to say like iconoclastic
but he's a very very like anti-authority
he's a very
um he doesn't really like the whole he
doesn't like the whole studio system he
doesn't like he likes to do his own
thing so it's like if he makes a movie
and people don't really get it like he
gets kind of like pissed off about it
and then like then later on like he
makes a movie he's like I thought this
was the best movie ever and you guys
didn't get it and then like 10 years
later it was like oh my God it's the
best movie ever he's like man [ __ ] you
guys yeah I told you this was the best
movie ever 10 years ago you don't listen
to me so I totally get that I totally
get that he has that attitude he had a
lot of good movies they live that's what
I mean and it's like yeah a lot of his
movies were like not that great but it's
like holy [ __ ] who else has that yeah
and it's like look John Carpenter is
awesome like he's one of my favorite
directors one of my other favorite
directors Dario Argento he probably only
made what like six seven eight like
great movies and the rest of kind of
sucked
um but [ __ ] man it's like
what are you gonna do it's you you can't
like [ __ ] everybody can't like [ __ ]
hit a home run all the time I'm not
gonna [ __ ]
and I honestly I kind of feel like if
we're coming down to it I'd have to like
look at their
respective IMDb pages I think I kind of
feel like John Carpenter might have made
better like more better movies than
Argento did yeah although I'm not gonna
almost all the Carpenters movies now I'm
gonna say like my my favorite favorite
directors yeah are David Lynch and
Stanley Kubrick and I will say that
David Lynch and Stanley Kubrick I can't
think of a bad movie that either one of
them made well although David Lynch you
could make an argument for like Dune but
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna be mad
because that like that that was great
movie I liked it and the thing about it
is that I don't know if he had like as
much control as he would normally have
so I'm just gonna give him a pass on
that one but honestly like I can't think
of a single Stanley Kubrick movie or a
single single David Lynch movie that I
didn't like and then Cronenberg Ann
Cronenberg also I can't think of a
single day of a Cronenberg movie that I
didn't like like all of them are totally
worth watching
um you know John Carpenter Dario Argento
those two are kind of like you know they
had like some really really brilliant
films like some of my favorite films
ever and then some movies that were like
you know what I mean yeah
um so you know they're a little bit I
don't want to say like second tier but
they're kind of like not as high up
maybe as like you know Lynch or Kubrick
or you know that kind of thing but it's
you know what are you gonna like I said
any director is lucky to have one movie
that's [ __ ] brilliant
that everybody remembers so I'm not
gonna like [ __ ] on people that I'm awake
again yeah I noticed you're back I'm
back
I gotta get we're gonna get something to
eat though
Isabella said Hitchcock is remarkable
really he made maybe 70 movies many very
good yeah that's the thing like a lot of
Hitchcock's movies were good too yeah
and I mean he made some
he made some woofers like later on in
his career but all of them were worth
watching worth watching
and I kind of feel like the same is true
of
you know John Carpenter or Dario Argento
or something like that like a lot of
them well okay as far as Dario Argento
if you guys have watched my recent
review that I posted the other day about
mother of tears from
2007 or whatever that movie came out
um
I would argue that if you're into Dario
Argento I would advise probably not
watching any movies of his past about
1996 or so you know what I mean
um because you'll just be bummed out but
you know so I I think he kind of he's
still alive like he's in his 80s but um
you know I think he kind of lost the
plot a little bit but some of the [ __ ]
like after that worthwhite like dark
glasses was okay that came out this year
it was fine it wasn't anything special
but it was fine
um you know but
I don't know I I do kind of feel like
like you said directors artists in
general do have a half-life but not
always it kind of depends on
what they're doing who they are [ __ ]
like that
you know
we talked about John Carpenter
earlier like I posted a video earlier
today where we were talking about
Village of the Damned like John
Carpenter's uh remake of Village of the
Damned and
while it wasn't fantastic it was
actually like a it was a watchable movie
though it was a watchable movie I don't
know if it was better than the original
because I haven't seen the original in a
long time but
I don't know I think there were things
about it that I liked better than the
original just saying
um
yeah they're talking about duel Zach
says I think my favorite Spielberg movie
is Color Purple
that movie made me cry my eyes out that
was actually like a great movie and I
haven't seen in a long time
do you remember Color Purple hmm
maybe you didn't see it I think I saw
the theater yeah it was really good
uh Zach said it wasn't that the case
with everything Kubrick did
baby maybe I also really love Empire of
the Sun yeah that was a great movie too
that was a great movie too
but you know are you you seem like you
want to go yeah well I have to I have to
cook
are you gonna be all right yeah now that
you're awake yeah
[Laughter]
it's a problem he's getting mad at me no
I'm getting mad because of course I'm
fine well I don't know I gotta check
yeah I gotta check you're not real you
weren't real coherent for most of the
show so we'll make something to eat okay
what are you gonna make
what are you gonna make mixed with soup
and some sandwiches soup and sandwiches
that sounds good actually yeah all right
well okay hopefully you guys have a good
rest of your Friday night and good day
tomorrow uh we're gonna sign off for the
evening Tom's gonna go make some food
he's been at the biker bar all day it's
been it's it's a whole thing
so we'll be back Sunday now on Sunday
for the matinee show we're going to be
talking about
the Spanish language Dracula yeah from
1931. good movie The Universal one
because we watched it it's on 2B yeah
um because we were curious because
remember we talked about the Bella
Lugosi Dracula from 1931 and I mentioned
that there was a Spanish language
version that they shot at the same time
like at night while they were shooting
the Dracula during the day so we were
curious and so we watched it and we're
gonna say like in some ways it actually
was Superior yeah uh so yeah we wanted
to talk about that so we did like watch
it so we're going to talk about that on
Sunday and then on Monday we're gonna do
a haunting like we always do I don't
know what top what uh episode we're
gonna do yet Tuesday we're going to be
talking about
Dracula's daughter the second movie in
the it's Dracula 2. Dracula 2 Electric
booger yeah yeah it's gonna be like that
it's a yeah so we're gonna be talking
about dragon's daughter so we watched
that last night it was gonna be talking
about that too yeah so that's what's
coming up we're gonna do more Universal
monster movies because you guys seem to
like this and we like doing this as well
so hopefully you guys have a good rest
of your evening have a good day tomorrow
we will see you guys on Sunday evening
we're gonna talk about Spanish Dracula
and we'll see you guys then good